>> WANT TO START OUT APOLOGIZING
THAT
WE'RE STARTING A BIT LATE.
IT HAS BEEN.
WE ARE IN OUR BUSY SEASON HERE
IN THE CAPITAL.
YOU WILL SEE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WILL LEAVE THE COMMITTEE,
COME BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE COMMITTEES,
EITHER FOLKS PRESENTING OR
VOTING.
SO WE WANT TO SEND AN APOLOGY
EARLY AND OFTEN.
TODAY.
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL,
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
I AM LATE IS BECAUSE IT'S ONE
OF THOSE DAYS AND SINCERELY
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
AND DON'T MEAN TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL.
SO WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO DO IS CALL
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE TO
ORDER.
LET'S TURN IT OVER TO MADAM
SECRETARY
TO BE ABLE TO CALL THE ROLL.
>> MCGUIRE.
HERE.
MCGUIRE.
GROVE.
EGGMAN.
HERE.
JONES.
LAIRD.
HERE.
QUORUM.
A QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED.
SENATOR GROVE WILL BE BACK.
SHE IS CURRENTLY IN AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE.
WE KNOW THAT SENATOR LAIRD HAS
COMMITTEES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE COMING UP.
AND SENATOR LAIRD, IF YOU SEE
THE ROADRUNNER DUST BEHIND HIM,
HE'S RUN INTO HIS COMMITTEE.
SO POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE.
I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR EGGMAN.
SENATOR EGGMAN, IT IS A BIG DAY
TODAY WITHIN
THE EGGMAN HOUSEHOLD AND WELL
DESERVED.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TURN IT OVER
TO SENATOR EGGMAN ABOUT THE
HONOR
THAT WAS JUST BESTOWED TO
SENATOR EGGMAN
BY THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD.
PLEASE.
>> THANK YOU.
I WAS AWARDED THE THE ORDER OF
CALIFORNIA,
WHICH IS THE HIGHEST SECOND TO
THE SECOND
TO THE HIGHEST TO THE MEDAL OF
FREEDOM AWARD
BY THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD.
HEY!
SO WEARING THIS THE REST OF
MY TIME.
UH, IT REALLY IS A SPECIAL
HONOR.
AND ESPECIALLY AS A VETERAN
HERSELF.
SO, UM, PRETTY AMAZING AND AN
EMOTIONAL DAY.
SO CONGRATULATIONS AND WELL
DESERVED.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, COMMITTEE,
WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE UP OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE
BUSINESS HERE TODAY TO THE
APPOINTEES
WHO ARE IN FRONT OF US.
IF YOU DON'T MIND, WE'RE GOING
TO SPEND ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES TAKING UP OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE,
OUR HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS,
AND WE'LL COME RIGHT OVER TO
OUR FIRST PRESENTATIONS.
UM, IF THERE ARE NO OBJECTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE,
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TURN
TO GOVERNOR
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR.
WE HAVE ITEMS TWO D THROUGH J,
ITEMS TWO D THROUGH J.
IS THERE A MOTION?
SO MOVE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
LAIRD.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MCGUIRE I MCGUIRE I GROVE EGGMAN
EGGMAN
I JONES A JONES I LAIRD I LAIRD
I.
UNCLE.
IT'S A40 VOTE FOUR ZERO VOTE.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THAT ON
CALL FOR MADAM VICE CHAIR.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO BILL REFERRALS.
THIS IS ITEM THREE REFERENCE OF
BILLS TO COMMITTEES.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE.
SO MOVED.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
LAIRD.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL
THE ROLL MCGUIRE I MCGUIRE.
I GROVE EGGMAN EGGMAN I JONES
JONES
I LAIRD LAIRD I ON CALL 4.
TO 0 FOUR ZERO ON CALL FOUR ZERO
ON CALL FOR VICE CHAIR.
GROVE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE ADVANCING
TO FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS.
WE'D LIKE TO TAKE UP ITEMS FOUR
THROUGH SIX.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL?
MCGUIRE I.
MCGUIRE I GROVE EGGMAN I EGGMAN
I JONES
I JONES I LAIRD I LAIRD I 4 TO
0 ON CALL.
FOR ZERO UN.
CALL FOR ZERO UN.
CALL FOR SENATOR GROVE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING
INTO OUR BUSINESS TODAY.
AND WE WELCOME APPOINTEES.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH ITEM ONE A.
AND WE ARE HONORED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE DOCTOR,
DOCTOR DHINGRA TO BE ABLE TO
COME FORWARD, PLEASE,
FROM THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD
ALONG WITH DOCTOR YIP,
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
AS WELL.
UM, WE'RE GOING TO GET STARTED
IN 30S HAVE YOU GET SITUATED,
WE'RE GOING TO GET YOU SOME
WATER
AND WE'LL GET STARTED HERE
MOMENTARILY.
DOCTORS.
WE WANT TO FIRST AND FOREMOST
WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE AND SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA
AND TO THE PEOPLE OF STATE OF
CALIFORNIA,
AND IN PARTICULAR, UM, SERVING
THOSE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WHO YOU OVERSEE
AT THE BOARD.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO
IS HEAR FROM YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO OFFER YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE ANY WELCOME REMARKS
UP TO TWO MINUTES.
IN YOUR WELCOMING REMARKS,
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ANY FRIENDS OR FAMILY WHO MAY
BE HERE OR WATCHING ONLINE.
I'LL GIVE YOU A 32ND PROMPT
AS YOU
GET CLOSE TO THOSE TWO MINUTES.
AND THEN WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SO WHY DON'T WE START, MR.
DOCTOR, WITH YOU.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK.
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
>> SO GOOD AFTERNOON, MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE,
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY.
AND I WANT TO THANK GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM FOR CONSIDERING
ME AND APPOINTING ME TO THE
BOARD.
I WILL ALSO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY
TO THANK MY FAMILY,
ESPECIALLY MY WIFE, MINA,
WHO'S ALSO A FAMILY MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN
SERVING IN HEALTH SERVICES
IN CLOVIS FOR THE LAST 17 YEARS
AND ALWAYS SUPPORTED ME.
UM.
IN LAST 27 YEARS OF MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER,
I HAVE WORKED IN DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY,
WORKED WITH THE VERY DIVERSE
POPULATION,
PATIENT POPULATION SUBSET,
MOSTLY UNDERSERVED AND LAST
SEVEN YEARS,
17 YEARS BEING IN FRESNO,
CALIFORNIA.
I AM VERY CONFIDENT THAT MY, UH,
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE WILL
HELP ME IN THIS ROLE.
I WAS VERY FORTUNATE TO SERVE IN
A DIFFERENT LEADERSHIP ROLES,
WHETHER IT IS THE CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT
OR THE FOUNDING PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR INTERNAL MEDICINE
AT SAINT AGNES HOSPITAL,
OR THE LEADER OF MY OWN GROUP
FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS,
OF WHICH IS 5050 PLUS PROVIDER
GROUP NOW AND SERVING
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND
CURRENTLY BEING THE CHAIR
OF MEDICAL STAFF AT THE SAINT
AGNES HOSPITAL.
SO TODAY, I WANT TO COMMIT TO
THIS COMMITTEE THAT I WILL
WORK VERY DILIGENTLY AND
SINCERELY
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
COHESIVELY WITH THE MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES ON THE BOARD,
THE EXECUTIVE STAFF OF THE
MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA,
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, THIS
LEGISLATURE,
TO ENSURE AND ENHANCE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY.
WANT ME TO THANK YOU.
MR.
BOARD MEMBER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
OPENING REMARKS, DOCTOR.
WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT OVER
TO YOU
AND SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU A 32ND HEADS UP.
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, ESTEEMED MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU PULL
THE MICROPHONE A LITTLE CLOSER.
SIR.
I APOLOGIZE ABOUT INTERRUPTING,
MR.
BOARD MEMBER.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
YOU TURNED IT OFF.
OH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
YEAH.
GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
UM.
ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF THE SENATE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND MY
SINCERE GRATITUDE
TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT.
AND ALSO THE STAFF OF THE SENATE
RULES
COMMITTEE FOR ARRANGING THIS.
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING
A MULTI-ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES OF LOS ANGELES SINCE
1987,
ALMOST FOUR DECADES SERVING THE
MEDICAID,
MEDICARE, AND HMO HOMELESS
POPULATION.
IT IS AN HONOR TO SERVE THEM AS
A MEDICAL DOCTOR,
AND ALSO COMING TO SERVE AS
THEIR, UM,
AS A BOARD MEMBER OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD.
I'M EAGER TO CONTRIBUTE MORE
TOWARDS
ENHANCING PUBLIC SAFETY,
INTEGRITY, AND THE QUALITY
OF THE MEDICAL PROFESSION.
I TRULY HOPE THAT TOGETHER,
WE CAN BUILD GREATER TRUST
BETWEEN THE PUBLIC AND THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY.
THE MEDICAL BOARD FACES NUMEROUS
CHALLENGES AHEAD.
AS A BOARD MEMBER, I'M HONORED
TO BE PART OF
THE TEAM COMMITTED TO MEETING
THE GOALS
AND ENSURING THE HIGHEST QUALITY
OF CARE
AND HEALTH CARE FOR ALL IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND AGAIN, THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
I ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY WIFE FOR
44 YEARS WHO
HAD AN UBER ACCOUNT SO I CAN
COME HERE TODAY.
AND ALSO MR.
AARON BOWEN, WONDERFUL STAFF
ON THE BOARD
TO MAKE ME A MORE EFFICIENT
BOARD MEMBER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
BOARD MEMBER.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO
IS OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE POLICE,
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR LAIRD.
>> THANK YOU.
UM, AND AS THE CHAIR SAID,
I APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I HAVE TO
GO PRESENT
A BILL THE MINUTE I'M DONE
ANSWERING THESE,
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS.
BUT, UH, REST ASSURED, MR.
CHAIR, I'LL BE BACK FOR YOU.
UH, BUT I WILL BE BACK TO VOTE.
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THE IN AND
OUT.
I WANT TO START WITH DOCTOR YIP
AND MAYBE
WITH AN UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTION.
AND THAT IS IS SENATOR GROVE
AND I ARE
THE TWO STILL ON THE COMMITTEE?
BUT WE HAD MEDICAL BOARD
HEARINGS THAT WERE TWO
AND THREE YEARS AGO THAT WERE
REALLY DIFFICULT.
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES DID AN
INVESTIGATIVE STORY,
AND THEY FOUND THAT TEN
PHYSICIANS
THAT HAD COMMITTED
FAIRLY EGREGIOUS ERRORS THAT I
WON'T DESCRIBE
HERE HAD BEEN IN FRONT OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD,
AND NINE OF THEM WERE, UH, IT
WAS REVOKING
THEIR LICENSE WAS NOT ACCEPTED,
AND THEY WERE ALLOWED TO COME
BACK.
AND THEN FOUR OF THEM COMMITTED
FAIRLY EGREGIOUS ERRORS AFTER
THE ACTION OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
BACK WITH PATIENTS AGAIN.
AND WE HAD A DISCUSSION HERE
IN A VERY DIFFICULT ONE.
AND AND YOUR COLLEAGUES DID NOT
GET UNANIMOUS
VOTES IN MOVING OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AND WHILE YOU'RE COMING BACK
AND I READ
EVERYTHING AND YOU'RE LOOKING
FORWARD,
I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK BACK
FOR A SECOND,
BECAUSE YOU WERE THERE WHEN ALL
THAT HAPPENED.
SO HOW DO YOU REFLECT ON
THE ACTIONS THAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD DID OR DIDN'T TAKE AT
THAT TIME?
AND DO YOU HAVE REGRETS, AND HOW
DOES IT INFORM
YOU WANTING TO COME BACK NOW AND
SERVE AGAIN?
YEAH, IT'S ACTUALLY A VERY
EXCELLENT QUESTION.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE REASON
I WANT
TO COME BACK AFTER NINE YEARS.
UM, THE IT IS DISTURBING WHEN
WE READ
THOSE STORIES AS A BOARD MEMBER,
BUT SINCE I'VE BEEN THERE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS OR NINE YEARS,
WE TALKED TO DIFFERENT CHIEFS
AND TALKED TO THEM,
AND HOW CAN WE DO BETTER?
IT'S ALWAYS EASY JUST TO SAY,
WELL,
THIS DOCTOR IS NO GOOD, LET'S
SHUT HIM DOWN.
BUT WE HAVE A LEGAL PROCESS TO
FOLLOW.
WE HAVE THE RULES TO FOLLOW.
WE AND ADVISE TO THE DAG SO THAT
WE CAN BUILD A GOOD CASE SO THAT
WE WON'T LOSE IT BECAUSE WE ACT,
UH, WITHOUT THE EVIDENCE.
UM, DURING THE YEARS, WE ALSO
TRY TO HAVE THE BOARD
TO ASK YOUR HELP TO GET MORE
LEGISLATIVE,
UH, CHANGE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
MORE POWER TO SUBPOENA,
RECORD, OR USE IT TO ISSUE A
SUSPENSION ORDER SO
THAT WE CAN PROTECT THE PUBLIC
MORE SWIFTLY.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE TRY TO
WORK ON MORE AGGRESSIVELY TO
CHANGE THAT.
AND THE DIFFICULTY OF OUR
HEARINGS WERE
WE HAD FAMILY MEMBERS TESTIFYING
OF
PEOPLE THAT HAD BEEN IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES,
AND IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL IF THERE HAVE
BEEN ANY CHANGES IN THE LAW?
IT EMPOWERS YOU TO TAKE ACTION
NOW
THAT YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE
TO TAKE DURING YOUR FIRST TIME
AROUND ON THE MEDICAL BOARD.
UM, ASIDE, PUT IN MY RESPONSE TO
THE QUESTIONNAIRE,
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
SUGGESTIONS I MAKE SEVERAL
YEARS AGO TO HAVE THE TRACKING
SYSTEM,
AND I WAS THE ONE THAT BROUGHT
ON.
WE SHOULD LET THE COMPLAINANT
AND
THE FAMILY KNOW WHERE THE CASE
STANDS,
RATHER THAN LIKE, DIP IN THE SEA
AND NOBODY KNOWS WHAT'S GOING
ON.
AND WE'RE WORKING ON THAT
TRACKING SYSTEM.
SECOND, ALSO THE REASON.
COMPLAINT.
UH, UNIT THAT WE CAN TALK TO THE
COMPLAINANT.
WHAT WERE THE ISSUE?
TAKE THE STATEMENT.
THE IMPACT STATEMENT?
THAT'S ANOTHER CHANGE.
I THINK WE LEARNED FROM THE
MEDICAL BOARD.
WE NEED TO LISTEN TO THE PUBLIC
MORE.
UM, AS I TELL MY STAFF, WE SEE
50 PATIENTS A DAY,
BUT THE PATIENT ONLY SEE ONE
DOCTOR THAT DAY.
SO TO THEM, IT'S A BIG DEAL.
AND I THINK THE BOARD WE'RE
BUILDING A CULTURE
THAT WE'RE MORE OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC
AND ACT ON THAT AND MAKE CHANGES
AND HOPEFULLY
WITH THE HELP OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
OKAY.
AND THEN THAT AND I APPRECIATE
IT.
AND JUST TAKE OUR CONCERN VERY
SERIOUSLY.
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE ALSO
REPRESENT THE PATIENTS,
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION THAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD HASN'T
RETURNED SOMEBODY INTO PRACTICE.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO TO DEAL
WITH THEM.
WELL, BUT YOU TEED UP A
LEGISLATION AND BUDGET,
AND I THOUGHT THAT WOULD JUST BE
MY SECOND QUESTION.
AND AND MAYBE I'LL GIVE YOU A
WELL-EARNED REST
AND START WITH THE OTHER, UH,
CANDIDATE.
BUT THE QUESTION IS, IS,
IS THERE HAVE BEEN BUDGET ISSUES
AND FOR A WHILE THERE WAS A
MASSIVE BACKLOG.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE MEDICAL
BOARD HAS BEEN
ADDRESSING THOSE IN A WAY TO
GET AT THEM?
WELL, THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION.
I THINK, UH, UM, I JUST STARTED
MY I JUST ATTENDED
ONE BOARD MEETING AND WHAT I
LEARNED,
THE SUNSET BILL HAS ALLOWED US
TO INCREASE THE PHYSICIAN
LICENSING FEE FROM BEGINNING
OF THIS YEAR.
AND THE SECOND INCREASE PROBABLY
WILL HAPPEN IN 2027.
SO THAT WILL GIVE US A LITTLE
FINANCIAL
HELP TO HIRE THE MORE STAFF.
I THINK THE BACKLOG IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
IT TAKES THE COMPLAINT TO
ADJUDICATE
AROUND 3 TO 4 YEARS.
THE THE PROBLEM IS NOT JUST THE
STAFF,
IT IS THE EXPERTS WHICH WE DON'T
HAVE,
AND WE NEED TO FIND A DIFFERENT
WAYS
TO HIRE AND GIVE THE
COMPETITIVE,
YOU KNOW, REIMBURSEMENT FOR
THEIR EXPERT REVIEW.
AND I THINK THIS SB, THE SUNSET
BILL WILL
HELP US TO FINANCIALLY BECOME
MORE,
YOU KNOW, MORE VIABLE IN TERMS
OF HIRING ALL THESE STAFF.
SO THAT'S ONE PART OF THE STORY.
AND THE SECOND PART IS THE, UH,
THE LICENSING PROCESS FOR THE
CANDIDATES
IS ALSO BACKLOGGED,
BUT IT HAS IMPROVED
SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE THIS, UH,
THIS FINANCIAL THING HAS
HAPPENED,
AND NOW YOU ARE ABLE TO.
RESPOND TO THE APPLICANT WITHIN
20 TO
30 DAYS AND THE FIRST
APPLICATION.
SO I THINK THE PROCESS IS MUCH
FASTER.
SO IN MY OPINION, WHATEVER
THE INCREASE HAS BEEN DONE,
IT IT IS GOING TO HELP, UH, THE
MEDICAL BOARD.
AND YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE LETTING
US
KNOW IF THAT'S NOT GOING THAT
WAY.
AND THERE'S NECESSARY HELP YOU
NEED
FROM THE LEGISLATOR, OF COURSE.
AND, DOCTOR, LET ME GIVE YOU
A CHANCE ON THAT QUESTION.
WELL, UM, IT'S ACTUALLY A KIND
OF COMPLICATED QUESTION,
THE WAY THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
BLAME THE COVID TIME.
THERE'S A TIME THAT PEOPLE
CANNOT DO AS USUAL,
HAVE REGULAR MEETING.
BUT AS DOCTOR DEAN WOULD SAY,
WE'RE WORKING ON INCREASE THE
EXPERT REVIEWER.
I PERSONALLY INVOLVED IN THE
TRAINING IN APRIL,
ONE COMING IN AUGUST,
AND I REACHED OUT TO THE MEDICAL
SCHOOL, LOMA LINDA,
UH, UCI AND USC TO ENCOURAGE THE
ACADEMIC BUT ALSO
COMMUNITY PHYSICIAN TO JOIN THE
EXPERT REVIEWER.
WE ALSO DID AN ONLINE MODULE,
HOPEFULLY THAT MAKE MORE
PHYSICIANS TO JOIN,
NOT ONLY JUST FOR THE MONEY,
BUT ALSO HOPEFULLY THEY SHARE
THE PASSION OF
THE INTEGRITY OF THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION.
YOU ARE A DOCTOR, NOT JUST
BECAUSE
OF THE EMBARRASSMENT YOUR
DOCTOR,
ALSO BECAUSE OF THE CARE THE
PATIENT
ARE OF THE COMMUNITY.
UM, THE OTHER THING WE'RE
WORKING
ON IS ALSO TO TRAIN THE STAFF.
NOW WE ALWAYS HEAR WE HAVE
VACANCY
IN THE INVESTIGATION, 15%, 25%.
SO OUR CHIEF REALLY WORKING
ON IT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU, UH, BEFORE
I LEFT
THE MEDICAL BOARD, TWO AND 22.
AND NOW WHENEVER I CALL MY CHIEF
OF ENFORCEMENT OR AARON,
UM, WEEKEND 9 P.M., THEY
RESPOND.
THEY WORK.
UM, TO ANSWER QUESTION.
WE ARE LESS STAFF, BUT THEY WORK
HARDER.
AND I'M TRYING TO AND THEY
TRYING TO IMPROVE
THE MORALE OF THE WHOLE MEDICAL
BOARD TEAM.
SO.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WILL
BE BACK TO VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD,
PLEASE.
UH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, DOCTORS.
NICE TO SEE YOU HERE.
UM, I'VE SERVED ON THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE SINCE 2012, I THINK
SO,
IN TWO HOUSES AND AND EVERY YEAR
THERE'S ISSUES WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD THAT COME THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE
AND A LOT OF CONTROVERSY.
AND WE DEAL WITH.
AND I KNOW THE, UM, THE TRAILER
BILL
LANGUAGE YOU REFERRED TO OR
THE SUNSET BILL YOU REFERRED TO,
UH, PASSED LAST YEAR, I THINK.
AND IT WILL ALSO INCLUDE, IN
ADDITION
TO INCREASING FINES,
UH, BRINGING THE FAMILIES INTO
THE PROCESS.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU ANTICIPATE
THAT'S GOING
TO BE ABLE TO HELP YOU COME TO
DECISIONS?
I THINK, IS THE IMPACT, UM,
IMPACT EFFECT OR THE PATIENT
IMPACT?
I THINK THE IT IS A VERY GOOD
IDEA
AND I THINK IT SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGED.
THE MEDICAL BOARD IS WORKING
VERY DILIGENTLY ON IT,
AND WE PROBABLY SEND AROUND 150,
UM, INQUIRIES ON THAT.
THE RESPONSE IS NOT VERY, VERY
POSITIVE.
IT'S ONLY TEN PEOPLE HAVE
RESPONDED.
BUT I THINK THE MEDICAL BOARD IS
COMMITTED TOWARDS THAT CAUSE.
AND WE ARE VERY, VERY AS A FOR
MYSELF
AND AS A PART OF THE BOARD, I
HAVE OBSERVED,
THEY ARE VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
THE PATIENT CARE AND FAMILIES,
AND WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE THAT
AND FIND IF THESE THINGS ARE
NOT WORKING,
WHY THEY ARE NOT WORKING AND
TRY TO
IMPLEMENT IT MORE EFFECTIVELY.
UM.
SAME ACTUALLY.
INTERESTING.
THE STATISTICS SHOW WE ISSUE
MORE THAN 119 AND 20
IMPACT STATEMENT AND ONLY NINE
RESPONSE NOW.
UM CERTAINLY SOMETHING ASKED
AS MANY.
WE WANT TO LOOK AT THE PEOPLE
RESPOND
WHAT WERE THE QUALITY OR ISSUE.
WHEREAS THE OTHER ONE MAYBE
THIS IS A MINOR COMPLAINT.
SO THEY MAY SKEW THE STATISTIC.
BUT NINE NINE RESPONSE IS NINE
RESPONSE.
SO WE NEED TO TAKE A SERIOUS TO,
YOU KNOW TO LEARN WHAT IS
IMPORTANT.
BUT AT LEAST THE CHANNEL IS THAT
THE PATIENT AND
THE FAMILY CARETAKER HAS A WAY
TO EXPRESS THEIR CONCERN.
>> UM.
AND, AND SO YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF INQUIRIES
THAT YOU PUT OUT AND, AND THE
FEW THAT CAME BACK.
HOW LONG FROM THE COMPLAINT
WERE THOSE LETTERS ISSUED?
THOUGH, AS I UNDERSTAND THOSE
ARE BEING STILL
GOING THROUGH THE INVESTIGATION
PROCESS.
OKAY, THOSE ARE THE FIRST STEPS
TO GET THE RESPONSE RIGHT.
BUT I KNOW THERE WAS A BACKLOG
OF YEARS.
SO I'M THINKING IF YOU SEND A
LETTER
TO SOMEBODY FROM YEARS AGO,
THEY MAY NOT RESPOND RIGHT AWAY.
I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT TIMING,
BUT I'M DEFINITELY GOING TO LOOK
INTO IT AND GET BACK IF WE CAN.
WE CAN GIVE THAT INFORMATION
BACK TO THE THE COMMITTEE.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
AND AND I GUESS JUST THE,
THE PRIVILEGE IT IS FOR DOCTORS
TO HAVE A MEDICAL BOARD THAT
POLICE THEMSELVES BASICALLY.
UM, A LOT OF OTHER PROFESSIONS
MIGHT
HAVE OTHER PEOPLE LOOKING AT
THEM.
SO HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU THINK
ABOUT
THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT COMES
WITH THAT,
BOTH TO SOCIETY AND TO YOUR YOUR
PROFESSION?
TO ME, IT IS JUST AN EXTENSION
OF MY HIPPOCRATIC
OATH THAT DO NOT DO ANY HARM.
AND NOW YOU ARE ENABLED BY BY
THE MANDATE OR THE APPOINTMENT
THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING MORE THAN THAT.
AND TO ME, THIS IS VERY PATIENT
CENTRIC
APPROACH IN MY REAL LIFE ALSO,
AND AS A PART OF THE BOARD ALSO,
I STRONGLY BELIEVE IN THAT.
NOW YOU HAVE A.
RESOURCES AND SOME AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT THE IDEAS WHICH ARE
PATIENT CENTRIC AND HOPEFULLY
HELP THE PATIENT SAFETY.
SO I FEEL IT IS VERY IT'S
A GREAT PRIVILEGE AND HONOR
TO BE ON THE BOARD AS A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL,
BUT ALSO I WANT TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE MEMBER
OF THE BOARD TO TO MAKE SURE
THE MISSION OF THE BOARD IS
ACCOMPLISHED
IN A IN A POSITIVE WAY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
I THINK IN THE PAST I HAVE TO
MEET THE MEDICAL
MAY HAVE BEEN MORE ON THE
PASSIVE SIDE.
WAIT UNTIL THE COMPLAINT COME
IN AND ACT ON IT.
I THINK OVER THE YEAR WE
CHANGING,
BUT I THINK WE CAN CHANGE MORE.
WE NEED TO BE MORE AGGRESSIVE
OUTREACH.
AND I TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE BOARD AND ALSO THE DIRECTOR.
EACH BOARD MEMBER CAN ALWAYS
TELL THE SOCIETY,
ALP, SCHOOL STUDENT,
TALK TO THEM WHAT BEING A DOCTOR
IS ABOUT,
WHY THE TRUST BETWEEN THE PUBLIC
AND MEDICAL
PROFESSION HAS DETERIORATED OVER
THE YEARS.
HOW CAN WE BUILD IT UP?
IT'S IT'S NOT EASY, AS YOU KNOW,
THOSE COMING ABOUT THE NEW
GENERATION NOW.
BUT HOPEFULLY WE PICK THE DOCTOR
WHO WON'T BE DOCTOR.
THEY'RE DIFFERENT AND HOPEFULLY
THE MEDICAL BOARD CAN HELP
CHANGE THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY LAST BOARD
MEETING A NUMBER
OF BOARD MEMBER ACTUALLY SAY,
HEY, WE SHOULD WORK THE ED TO
BE MORE OUTREACH TO THIS,
UH, MEDICAL SCHOOL OR SOCIETY
OR SENIOR
CENTER TO TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC.
DEBT IS A CHANNEL FOR THE
COMPLAINT.
ALSO EDUCATE THE STUDENT, THE
RESIDENT, THE FELLOW,
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF BEING A
PHYSICIAN.
THANK YOU.
I'M A I'M AN LCSW.
W SO EVERY TIME I GO INTO A
SITUATION, RIGHT.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I ALWAYS
ASK ARE WHEN
I WAS A PROFESSOR TO ASK THE
STUDENTS LIKE,
WHO IS YOUR CLIENT?
SO I'D ASK BOTH OF YOU,
AS IN YOUR ROLE ON THE MEDICAL
BOARD,
WHO IS YOUR CLIENT?
WHO IS MY CLIENT?
AS THE PUBLIC.
THE PUBLIC.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT GOES WITH THE MISSION OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, DOCTORS, THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
HERE AND SEE NO OTHER DISCUSSION
FROM THE COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
DO IS OPEN
UP OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY PORTION.
WE'RE GOING TO INVITE ANY
INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE TWO BOARD MEMBERS.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE
TO THE PODIUM AT THIS TIME,
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION THAT
YOU'RE REPRESENTING,
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A 32ND
TIME LIMIT ON THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME.
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU.
>> I THANK YOU.
AND A SET SHORT REPRESENTING
SAINT AGNES MEDICAL CENTER
HERE URGING YOUR SUPPORT FOR
DOCTOR DHINGRA.
HE'S AN AMAZING HEALTH LEADER
AT SAINT AGNES,
WHERE HE IS ALSO WELL KNOWN AND
VALUED FOR HIS,
UM, ENCOURAGEMENT AND SUPPORT
FOR HIS COLLEAGUES,
HIS PROFESSION AND HIS
COMMUNITY.
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR HIS
NOMINATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ATTENDING.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO COME
UP AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A LAST CALL
FOR THOSE
WHO MAY WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NO ONE RISE, WE'RE NOW
GOING
TO REQUEST ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
TO THE PODIUM AT THIS TIME,
STATE YOUR FIRST AND LAST ALONG
WITH YOUR ORGANIZATION.
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO ONE RISE,
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
SEE IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HEARING NONE.
SOMEONE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO ADVANCE A MOTION FOR BOTH.
AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T SAY
I HAD OUTREACH FROM PHYSICIANS
IN MY COMMUNITY ABOUT DOCTOR
DHINGRA
AND HIS FINE SUPPORT.
AND SO I'LL MOVE THAT.
WE SEND BOTH OF THESE TO THE
SENATE
FLOOR FOR FULL CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL?
>> MAGUIRE I.
MAGUIRE I.
GROVE.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I.
JONES.
JONES I.
LAIRD.
AND 3 TO 0 AS THE.
3030 VOTE ON CALL FOR SENATOR
LAIRD AND SENATOR GROVE.
DOCTORS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL BE SHUTTING THIS
DOWN
HERE IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
AND AGAIN, TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THOSE WATCHING ONLINE,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A 32ND
PAUSE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MR.
CHAIR, IF YOU CAN PLEASE, PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A 32ND
PAUSE.
WE'RE GOING TO SWAP OUT THE NAME
PLATES
AND GET A FRESH CUP OF WATER.
AND WE'LL GET STARTED HERE IN
JUST A MOMENT.
>> OH, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SURE.
GREAT.
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE BACK.
WE WANT TO WELCOME MR.
HOCHSCHILD TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SIR.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU.
MR.
HOCHSCHILD, WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK, YOUR TENURE,
YOUR STEADY HAND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION.
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO A LITTLE
BIT OF A RUN, A SHOW.
WE'LL HAVE YOU PROVIDE UP TO
TWO MINUTES
OF WELCOMING REMARKS AT THAT
TIME.
WE REQUEST THAT YOU ACKNOWLEDGE
ANY FAMILY,
FRIENDS THAT ARE HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE
AND OR WATCHING ONLINE.
WHEN YOU GET CLOSE TO THAT TWO
MINUTES,
I'LL GIVE YOU A 32ND WARNING.
AND THEN WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
IS OPEN IT UP
FOR DISCUSSION AND DEBATE FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
AFTER YOU'VE CONCLUDED YOUR
WELCOMING REMARKS.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS, SIR, AND
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PRO TEM MCGUIRE, SENATORS AND
DISTINGUISHED AWARDEE.
UM, GOOD TO BE HERE.
I'M DAVID HOCHSCHILD, CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION.
AND WITH YOUR PERMISSION, I
JUST WANT
TO FIRST INTRODUCE MY AMAZING
WIFE,
CYNTHIA LEE, WHO'S HERE WITH ME.
UM, SHE'S A DOCTOR.
AND WHEN WE MARRIED 21 YEARS
AGO,
I WAS IN ENVIRONMENT,
CLEAN ENERGY, AND SHE WAS IN
HEALTH.
AND WE KIND OF THOUGHT OF THOSE
AS SEPARATE ISSUES.
AND IT'S REALLY BECOME CLEAR
THAT
THEY'RE INEXTRICABLY
INTERTWINED,
AND THAT WHEN WE CREATE A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT,
WE ARE ALSO PASSING ON HEALTH
TO THE NEXT GENERATION.
AND I TRY TO CARRY THAT
SENTIMENT
WITH ME IN ALL MY WORK.
I WANT TO JUST BEGIN BY THANKING
THE INCREDIBLE
TEAM AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION,
MY CHIEF OF STAFF, KAT ROBINSON,
OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR, DREW
BOHAN,
OUR WONDERFUL VICE CHAIR, SYLVIA
GUNDA,
WHO I'VE TASKED WITH LEADING US
ON GRID RELIABILITY,
SB 100 AND SB ONE TWO WORK
COMMISSIONER
NOMI GALLARDO,
WHO'S LEADING US ON LITHIUM
VALLEY AND ON OUR EQUITY
WORK AND ON ALL THE FAST TRACK
PERMITTING,
AS WELL AS COMMISSIONER ANDREW
MCALLISTER
ON BUILDING DECARBONIZATION,
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
COMMISSIONER
MONAHAN ON ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES.
AN INCREDIBLE TEAM THAT REALLY
KEEPS ME GOING.
UM, I DON'T WANT TO SUGARCOAT
IN ANY WAY THE SERIOUSNESS
OF THE ENERGY CHALLENGES THAT
WE FACE,
BECAUSE THE HILL AHEAD IS VERY
STEEP, UM,
CLIMATE DRIVEN HEAT DOMES, UH,
YOU KNOW,
STRESSING THE GRID, UH,
WILDFIRES THAT ARE CREATING,
YOU KNOW,
VERY EXPENSIVE UTILITY
UNDERGROUNDING
WORK THAT FALLS ON RATEPAYERS
PRICE VOLATILITY IN THE GASOLINE
MARKET THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED.
BUT I DO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE INCREDIBLE PROGRESS
THAT OUR STATE IS MAKING,
WHERE IT'S 61% CLEAN ENERGY ON
THE GRID.
WE'RE GOING TO HIT TWO THIRDS OF
OUR POWER IN THE NEXT YEAR.
BEING CLEAN ENERGY, THAT IS
SOMETHING PEOPLE
THOUGHT WAS IMPOSSIBLE EVEN A
FEW YEARS AGO.
WE'VE ADDED, IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS
22GW OF NEW POWER TO THE GRID.
92% OF THAT IS CLEAN.
AND OF THAT, THAT'S THE MOST
IN ANY FIVE
YEAR PERIOD IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY.
AND OF THAT, TEN GIGS IS BATTERY
STORAGE,
WHICH WE DID IN FIVE YEARS.
UNPRECEDENTED.
AND WHEN WE'RE DOING THESE
THINGS,
WE'RE CREATING MARKET
TRANSFORMATION.
THE NEXT TEN GIGS OF BATTERIES
IS GOING TO COME IN 50% LESS.
UM, WE'RE ALSO OPERATING AN
INCREDIBLY ROBUST
PROGRAM AROUND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY.
CALIFORNIA RANKS NUMBER ONE IN
THE UNITED STATES ON EFFICIENCY.
AND A LOT OF THIS IS WORK AT
THE SEC
THAT IS TOTALLY BELOW THE RADAR.
BUT WE'RE SAVING IN CALIFORNIA
$3.8
BILLION A YEAR BECAUSE OF THE
CCS
LIGHTING EFFICIENCY STANDARD,
NEARLY $2 BILLION A YEAR FROM
OUR
TELEVISION EFFICIENCY STANDARD,
$700 MILLION A YEAR FROM
COMPUTER STANDARDS.
AND AGAIN, THIS IS WORK THAT'S
WAY BELOW THE RADAR,
BUT HUGELY CONSEQUENTIAL.
AND WE'RE ALSO OPERATING THE
BEST CLEAN ENERGY
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
IN THE WORLD,
SUPPORTING OVER 340 CLEAN TECH
STARTUPS
AND INNOVATORS THAT ARE SCALING.
AND I'LL JUST WRAP WITH THIS.
YOU KNOW, SOLAR POWER IS
PROBABLY THE SINGLE BIGGEST
ENERGY LEGACY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
FIRST UTILITY SCALE SOLAR
PROJECT IN
THE WORLD AND ROOFTOP SYSTEMS
DEPLOYED HERE.
AND THAT BUILT AN INDUSTRY THAT
HAS SPREAD
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND THE
WORLD.
IN 2004, IT TOOK A YEAR GLOBALLY
TO BUILD A GIGAWATT OF SOLAR.
IN 2010, IT TOOK A MONTH.
IN 2016, IT TOOK A WEEK.
IN 2023, IT TOOK A DAY TO BUILD
A GIGAWATT
OF SOLAR 2024 HALF A DAY.
THE PRICE OF SOLAR HAS COME DOWN
98% SINCE 2000,
AND THAT'S THE KIND OF MARKET
TRANSFORMATION
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO SUPPORT.
IT'S HAPPENING WITH WIND,
IT'S HAPPENING WITH ENERGY
STORAGE,
IT'S HAPPENING WITH ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
AND REALLY THE R&D PROGRAM AND
THE POLICY PROGRAM
WE HAVE IS DRIVING THAT
MAINSTREAM.
WE'RE ALSO GOING WAY UPSTREAM ON
THINGS LIKE LITHIUM DEVELOPMENT.
WE HAVE ENOUGH LITHIUM IN
CALIFORNIA
TO BE SUSTAINABLY PRODUCED,
TO PROVIDE POWER,
ENOUGH BATTERIES FOR 375 MILLION
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE PRODUCED
ENTIRELY
WITH CLEAN ELECTRICITY.
SO I'LL WRAP THERE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
CHAIR.
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
AND AGAIN, WE WELCOME YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE
IF THERE
ARE ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO KICK US OFF
HERE,
PLEASE, MADAM VICE CHAIR.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MY APOLOGIES TO THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE
JUST CONFIRMED OR NOMINATED
TO GO TO
THE FLOOR FROM THE MEDICAL BOARD
AS I AM BOUNCING
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
COMMITTEES.
SO I DO APOLOGIZE.
UH.
CHAIRMAN, I APPRECIATE YOU
MEETING WITH ME YESTERDAY.
YOU KNOW THAT I REPRESENT THE
OIL
INDUSTRY AND THE ENERGY
INDUSTRY,
AND YOU EVEN MADE THE COMMENT
THAT
OUR COUNTY PRODUCES MORE,
UH, SOLAR AND WIND THAN ANY
OTHER
COUNTY IN THE STATE COMBINED.
ACTUALLY, WE DO OVER 53% OF THE
STATE'S RENEWABLE
ENERGY TRANSMISSION LINES ARE
AN ISSUE.
AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THAT,
UM, YOU HAD.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION I WANT TO
ASK YOU,
BUT WHEN YOU BROUGHT UP LITHIUM,
IT MADE ME THINK OF THE OTAY
MESA SITUATION THAT WE HAVE.
WE DIDN'T REALLY DISCUSS IT
YESTERDAY.
IT WAS JUST HEAVILY IN YOUR
COMMENTS,
IN YOUR INTRODUCTION,
THE OTAY MESA SITUATION, UM,
THE LITHIUM BATTERIES DOWN THERE
IN THAT STORAGE
FACILITY BURNED FOR ALMOST THREE
WEEKS.
UM, YOU MENTIONED YOUR BEAUTIFUL
WIFE THAT
IS HERE TODAY IN THE HEALTH
INDUSTRY.
UM, AND YOU TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THE HEALTH EFFECTS
OF ENERGY AND WHY WE NEED TO
MAKE TRANSITIONS.
UH, THERE'S HYDROGEN FLUORIDE
IN THESE UNIQUELY DANGEROUS,
STRONG IRON, ORGANIC OR
INORGANIC,
UM, LITHIUM BATTERIES.
AND WHEN THEY CATCH ON FIRE,
THEY CAN PUT UPWARDS OF 600
PARTS
PER MILLION IN THE AIR OF THIS,
UH, HYDROGEN FLUORIDE.
AND TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE,
THE IDEA,
THE IDEA, UM, THE IDEA OR.
YOU KNOW, DEFINITELY, UM,
DANGEROUS TO HEALTH
OR DANGEROUS TO LIFE AND HEALTH.
CONCENTRATE IS 30 PARTS PER
MILLION.
SO WE'RE LIKE HUNDREDS OF PARTS
PER MILLION ABOVE WHAT THEY
ESTIMATED CAME INTO THE AIR,
INTO THAT SMALL COMMUNITY.
THAT'S A LOW SOCIOECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE.
COMMUNITY AVERAGE WAGE $71,000
A YEAR.
MOST POOR BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
LIVE IN THAT AREA.
AND THERE'S A LITHIUM BATTERY
STORAGE FACILITY THAT IS,
LIKE I SAID, ON FIRE.
AND TO MY KNOWLEDGE, CAL FIRE
COULDN'T PUT
IT OUT BECAUSE YOU CAN'T PUT
THEM OUT.
YOU HAVE TO LET THEM JUST BURN
OUT, RIGHT?
YOU HAVE TO TRY TO KEEP THE
BATTERIES COOL,
BUT LET THEM BURN OUT.
SO I GUESS, UM, WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHTS
ON LITHIUM BATTERY STORAGE,
ESPECIALLY IF WE HAVE THIS
EXPOSURE,
UM, YOU KNOW, TO LIFE AND
HEALTH.
UM, ACCORDING TO.
AND THAT'S A GOOD SOURCE.
IT COMES FROM THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT.
SO, UM.
CDPH SO JUST WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT?
YEAH.
SO TOTALLY FAIR QUESTION.
UM, AND A COUPLE UPDATES ON
THAT.
SO FOR ONE THING, UH, THERE WAS
A REALLY
BIG TURNING POINT IN 2021 WITH
THE NFPA,
NEW UL CODES, WHICH HUGELY
IMPROVED SAFETY.
SO IT'S EVERYTHING FROM BETTER
TELEMETRY
TO OTHER SAFETY MEASURES.
WE'RE TYPICALLY SEEING STORAGE
NOW
GO OUTSIDE IN ENCLOSED METAL
SHIPPING CONTAINER WITH SPACING
ON A CONCRETE FOUNDATION.
AND THE FIRES WE'VE HAD IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN NO INJURIES AND NO
FATALITIES.
BUT FIRE IS ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE IN ANY FORM.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
HAPPENING AS WELL IS THERE'S
TWO TYPES OF LITHIUM CHEMISTRIES
NMC AND RP.
RP IS MUCH LESS PRONE TO THERMAL
RUNAWAY AND
THE ENERGY STORAGE SPACE HAS
TRANSITIONED TO THAT.
SO THE INCIDENTS WE'RE SEEING,
THE ONE YOU'RE REFERRING TO
IN OTAY
MESA WAS AN NMC CHEMISTRY
BATTERY.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT, WE'RE
ENGAGING VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR PARTNER STATES, NEW
YORK AS WELL,
AND THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ON ADDITIONAL
SAFETY PROTOCOLS, CAL FIRE AS
WELL.
I WILL SAY ONE OF THE EXCITING
THINGS,
LOOKING AT THE SO WE'RE VERY
CLOSE
TO THE BATTERY ENERGY ECOSYSTEM.
THERE'S A BUNCH OF INNOVATION
HAPPENING
NOW THAT IS HUGELY HELPFUL IN
SAFETY.
SO CPR ON COMMERCIAL SPARKS
CUBERG LIMINAL ARE
SOME AMAZING COMPANIES BETTER
SEPARATORS,
BETTER DURABILITY, BETTER
TELEMETRY.
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT EVEN
THE FIRES THAT HAPPENED IN
THE EARLY VERSION OF THE CHEVY
BOLT,
WHICH IS LG CHEM,
THAT WAS THAT'S A TOTALLY
PREVENTABLE
THING BECAUSE THERE'S
A NEW PROCESS LEMNOS DEVELOPED
THAT YOU DO AN ULTRASOUND ON,
THAT YOU TACK IT ON TO THE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS.
YOU CAN DETECT A FLAWED CELL
AND TAKE
IT OUT BEFORE IT EVEN GETS TO
MARKET.
SO I WOULD SAY BIG PROGRESS ON
TECHNOLOGY.
WHAT I'M MOST CONCERNED ABOUT
ARE
THE LEGACY PRE 21 PROJECTS.
AND SO WE'RE ENGAGING WITH THEM.
I JUST MET WITH THE PROJECT
OPERATOR AND WE'RE
COMING UP WITH ADDITIONAL
PROTOCOLS ON THAT.
AND HOW MANY PROJECTS DO WE HAVE
LIKE THAT IN THE STATE IF WE.
HAVE, UH, TEN GIGAWATTS OF
BATTERY
STORAGE IN THE STATE TODAY.
UNDER THE OLD, OLD PROCESS?
UH, NO, NO, NOT ALL THAT'S
MOST OF THAT'S BEEN ADDED.
UH, MOST OF THE MOST, MOST OF
THAT HAS
COME ON IN THE LAST 2 OR 3
YEARS.
THE RATE OF BATTERY STORAGE HAS
GONE WAY UP.
YEAH.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YESTERDAY WE TALKED ABOUT A
CONVERSATION WHEN WE HAD
OUR CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR OF NEVADA.
UM, GOVERNOR LOMBARDO SENT
A LETTER TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
VOICING HIS CONCERNS REGARDING
THE GAS PRICES.
UM, SINCE 88% OF NEVADA'S GAS
COMES
FROM US HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
UM, IN OUR CALIFORNIA
REFINERIES.
UM, HE RAISES CONCERN ABOUT
THE COST INCREASES FOR
REFINERIES
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LACK OF
CAPACITY FOR REFINERIES.
BUT HE ALSO RAISED THE CONCERNS
ABOUT, OBVIOUSLY,
SB ONE TWO AND A PRICE MARKET
CAP,
WHICH COULD CREATE HIGHER COSTS
AND INCREASES.
AND THEN WE DISCUSSED THAT, UM,
I THINK IN DEPTH FOR THE I THINK
YOU WERE
IN MY OFFICE FOR ALMOST AN HOUR.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT, BUT IN
DEPTH.
SO I GUESS THE QUESTION IS LIKE,
WHAT'S THE PLAN?
SO THAT WE DON'T CREATE HIGHER
GAS PRICES?
I KNOW THE WHOLE AND AGAIN, THIS
IS NOT,
UM, ANYTHING AGAINST THE CEC
OR YOU.
I REALIZE THAT YOU'RE THE
IMPLEMENTER.
YOU'RE THE IMPLEMENTER.
YOU AND YOUR TEAM ARE THE
IMPLEMENTER OF
THE POLICY THAT'S PASSED OUT OF
THIS BUILDING,
EVEN IF SOMETIMES THAT POLICY
MAY BE IMPOSSIBLE
OR NEAR IMPOSSIBLE TO IMPLEMENT.
SO IT'S NOTHING BUT WHAT IS YOUR
THOUGHTS
AND PLANS TO ELIMINATE PRICE
SPIKES,
ESPECIALLY IN THE SUMMERTIME
WHEN WE'RE USING
A DIFFERENT FUEL BLEND THAT
COSTS MORE MONEY?
AND WHAT AND WHAT IS YOUR PLAN?
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
CONTINUALLY INCREASE
THE COST OF FUEL FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS?
YEAH.
SO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION.
UM, AND I'VE ASKED VICE CHAIR
SILVA
TO LEAD OUR EFFORTS IN THIS
SPACE.
UM, AND HE AND I HAVE MADE A
PERSONAL
COMMITMENT TO VISIT EVERY
SINGLE OPERATING REFINERY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TODAY.
THERE'S NINE OF THEM.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THAT.
AND THAT'S BEEN REALLY FRUITFUL
TO, UM,
GET INTO THE WEEDS OF THE ISSUE.
PRIOR TO THE SPECIAL SESSION
LAST YEAR,
THE ENERGY COMMISSIONS,
UH, AUTHORITIES ON THIS WERE
REALLY
JUST TRACKING THE MARKET.
WE HAD NO REGULATORY ROLE IN THE
OIL INDUSTRY.
WE DON'T REGULATE REFINERIES.
WE DON'T REGULATE OIL
PRODUCTION.
SO THIS IS A NEW AUTHORITY
THAT'S BEEN GRANTED TO.
WE'RE DOING OUR VERY BEST, UM,
TO SUPPORT, UM,
A SCENARIO WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
PRICE SPIKES.
AND I THINK A COUPLE OF THINGS
I REALLY
WANTED TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR
THE VISIBILITY ON DATA AND DATA
TRANSPARENCY
IS HUGELY HELPFUL FOR US.
ONE OF THE THINGS, FOR EXAMPLE,
THAT WE WORRY ABOUT IS,
UM, MAINTENANCE CYCLES STRIKING
WHEN DEMAND IS HIGHEST.
SO HAVING VISIBILITY ON THAT AND
THE 120 DAY NOTICE IS SUPER
HELPFUL.
WE NEVER WANT TO HAVE ALL THOSE
MAINTENANCE
CYCLES STACKED WHEN,
UH, YOU KNOW, WE EXPECT DEMAND
TO REALLY SPIKE,
WHICH IS LATE SUMMER, EARLY FALL
TIME FRAME,
AND TO REALLY BE ABLE TO PLAN
EFFECTIVELY AROUND THAT.
UM, AND THEN WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING
A MUCH MORE SORT OF DETAILED
ASSESSMENT.
UM, OBVIOUSLY, ANY ACTION WE
TAKE,
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE FULLY
UNDERSTAND
THE CONSEQUENCES AND,
UM, AND WE TAKE THAT ROLE REALLY
SERIOUSLY.
SO AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR THE NEW
AUTHORITIES.
AND WE'RE WE'RE DOING OUR BEST
TO TO MEET THAT NEED.
THANK YOU.
YOU PUT THE RIGHT MAN IN CHARGE
TOO.
HE'S HE IS, UM, VERY
INTELLIGENT,
VERY PROBLEM SOLVING AND THINKS
OUTSIDE THE BOX.
I LOVE HIM, HE'S GREAT.
UM, YOU MENTIONED SCHEDULED
MAINTENANCE, AND, UM.
BUT YESTERDAY, I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE IT ON THE RECORD,
TOO.
IS IS THAT SCHEDULED MAINTENANCE
IS MONITORED, BUT NOT SCHEDULED.
NOT UNSCHEDULED OR UNPLANNED.
ER, MAINTENANCE.
CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
YEAH.
UNPLANNED.
WE CAN NEVER PLAN.
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
ABOUT HAVING
A REGULAR PLANNED MAINTENANCE
CYCLE,
IF YOU DO THAT WELL YOU REDUCE
THE RISK OF UNPLANNED.
AND SO WE WANT TO SUPPORT THAT.
AND AND YOU KNOW I JUST WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE LEAD TIME
FOR THESE CREWS ON PLANNED
MAINTENANCE IS QUITE LONG.
IT CAN BE A YEAR AND A HALF TO
TWO YEARS.
AND SO, UM, GETTING AHEAD OF
THAT
AND RECOGNIZING THAT REALITY,
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
EASILY ADJUSTED.
UM, AND SO WE, WE SEE THE
CHALLENGE THERE.
AND, BUT THE VISIBILITY FOR
US IS
SOMETHING WE DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE.
AND NOW WE'RE GETTING THAT.
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY REALLY,
REALLY HELPFUL TO GET AHEAD
OF THIS.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU RECOGNIZE
THAT BECAUSE I THINK SOMETIMES
IF YOU'VE NEVER BEEN TO A
REFINERY,
NEVER OPERATED A REFINERY,
TO THINK THAT YOU HAVE TO
SCHEDULE
A JOB OUT ONE AND A HALF
TO TWO YEARS AWAY AND MAKE SURE
YOU KEEP THAT TIME.
AND THEN IF SOMETHING HAS TO
CHANGE,
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO MOVE
THOSE CREWS INTO THIS,
UH, FACILITY TO DO THE
MAINTENANCE THAT YOU NEED.
THE LAST QUESTION I HAVE IS, UM,
HOW DOES THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION
ENVISION HYDROGEN CONTRIBUTING
TO
THE STATE'S FUTURE CLEAN ENERGY?
UM, AS AS A STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY
CARRIER?
AND WHAT STRATEGIES DOES
THE CEC ADVOCATE FOR SUPPORT
OF ADOPTION OF INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT,
PARTICULARLY IN TRANSPORTATION
AND INDUSTRIAL SECTORS?
YEAH.
SO TWO PART QUESTION, UM,
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION SPACE,
UM, YOU KNOW,
THE GOAL THAT HAS BEEN SET IS
NOT AN ELECTRIC GOAL.
IT'S A ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
GOAL.
UH, SO AS PART OF THAT, WE WERE
GIVEN DIRECTION BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO DEPLOY
HYDROGEN
REFUELING STATIONS.
WE SPENT ALMOST $300 MILLION
ON THAT.
UH, WE'RE SECOND ONLY TO JAPAN
ON A PER CAPITA BASIS.
UM, WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
HYDROGEN SPACE?
IT'S REALLY MOVING INCREASINGLY
TOWARDS HEAVY DUTY.
UM, AND WE'RE FOCUSED AS WELL
ON SUPPORTING
RELIABILITY IN THOSE STATIONS.
THERE'S DEFINITELY BEEN SOME
ISSUES WITH THAT.
SO WE HAVE ABOUT 65 STATIONS UP
AND OPERATING.
WE'RE REALLY LOCKING IN TO MAKE
SURE
THOSE OPERATE SUCCESSFULLY.
WE HAD HAD A MORE ROBUST PROGRAM
IN THE BUDGET.
UM, WITH BUDGET CONDITIONS HAVE
CHANGED A BIT.
UH, SO TO DO TO DO MORE GREEN
HYDROGEN,
THERE'S OTHER AREAS THAT I WOULD
SAY,
YOU KNOW, WE REALLY WANT TO LOOK
TOWARDS CLEAN HYDROGEN,
YOU KNOW, AREAS THAT ARE HARD
TO ELECTRIFY,
SOME OF THE INDUSTRIAL
APPLICATIONS.
UM, AND BUT THAT'S NOW PENDING,
UH, FUTURE BUDGET ALLOCATIONS.
WELL, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I ASKED THAT QUESTION BECAUSE,
UM, UH,
ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS GAVE
IT TO ME
BECAUSE THEY WERE ACTUALLY
CONVERTING
SHORT TERM DELIVERY PLANES IN
MOJAVE.
THEY CAN GO UP TO 300 MILES JUST
CONVERTING A FUEL ENGINE,
UH, TO HYDROGEN, AND THEY JUST
REUSE THE SAME WATER.
AND IT'S PRETTY.
INTERESTING.
IS THAT UNIVERSAL, THE PLANT?
YEAH.
ONE THING I SHOULD SAY.
UM, SENATOR, I NEGLECTED TO
MENTION I WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
BUDGET.
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY THE ARCHES
GRANT THAT CAME IN THAT'S
NOT BEING MANAGED BY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION.
THAT'S OUR SISTER AGENCY,
GO-BIZ AND TYSON ACTUALLY ON
POINT FOR THAT.
AND THAT'S 1.2 BILLION.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LIKE I SAID, THERE'S NEW
TECHNOLOGY
EVERY DAY IN KERN COUNTY.
AND I JUST APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO
KEEP THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES
MOVING,
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE GOING TO
HELP MEET SOME
GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN SET BY THIS
LEGISLATURE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
CONFIRMATION, SIR.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MADAM VICE CHAIR, I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY,
PLEASE, SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HOW ARE YOU?
UM, I REPRESENT AREA IN THE
CENTRAL
VALLEY WHERE IT GETS REALLY HOT.
SO, UM, I I'VE HEARD IT.
I'M HOPING THERE'S NOT GOING TO
BE ANY, UM, UH,
DOWNTIMES THIS YEAR FOR
EVERYONE'S
AIR CONDITIONING AND POWER.
AND I KNOW THAT HAS A LOT HAS
TO DO WITH HYDRO,
UH, IN OUR MIX.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
WHAT WE HAVE AND WHAT'S COMING
ONLINE FOR YEARS.
WHEN WE DO HAVE A DROUGHT AND
WE KNOW
WE DON'T HAVE THE THE HYDROPOWER
BACK UP THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
AS A CUSHION FOR THIS YEAR.
YEAH.
SO FIRST OF ALL, OUR POSTURE
TODAY
FOR GRID RELIABILITY IS HUGELY
IMPROVED FROM WHAT IT WAS I
NEVER
WANT TO SAY NEVER OUTAGE.
BUT OUR I AM MUCH HAPPIER, UH,
THIS JUNE THAN I WAS LAST JUNE.
AND THAT'S IN LARGE PART A
CONSEQUENCE
OF ALL THE HARD WORK THAT'S GONE
TO TO DEPLOY ALL THESE NEW
RESOURCES,
IN PARTICULAR ENERGY STORAGE,
IN ADDITION TO THAT,
BECAUSE WE HAD A REALLY ROBUST
RAIN YEAR,
UM, VIRTUALLY EVERY MAJOR
RESERVOIR
IN THE STATE IS FULL.
AND SO THAT'S SUPER HELPFUL.
UM, IT'S EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
TO BUILD NEW HYDRO CAPACITY.
SO THERE'S NOT NOT A WHOLE LOT
AROUND THAT THAT'S HAPPENING.
BUT I THINK I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF SORT OF THE INTELLIGENT
USE OF EXISTING HYDRO CAPACITY
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
INTEGRATING THAT SUCCESSFULLY
WITH STORAGE SO THAT WE'LL
HAVE THAT HAVE THAT CAPACITY
WHEN, WHEN WE NEED TO.
AND JUST, YOU KNOW, TO YOUR
YOUR POINT
ABOUT INCREASED HEAT, YOU KNOW,
WE ARE CONCERNED FOR THE WHOLE
STATE BUT ALSO
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
UM, YOU KNOW, AND WE'RE ALREADY
THIS YEAR SEEING
FATALITIES FROM HEAT IN
CALIFORNIA IN JUNE.
UM, THAT'S THAT'S HAPPENING.
AND SO ELECTRICITY, YOU KNOW,
IS NOT AN OPTION.
IT'S A NECESSITY WHEN WE SEE IT
LIKE WATER.
AND SO THAT IS MY NUMBER ONE
CHARGE
IS TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON
AND CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH
THE PUC AND THE CAISO AND
OTHERS.
UM, AND I WILL SAY, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE ONLY HAD ONE OUTAGE ON
THE TRUNK CAISO SYSTEM SINCE
2021,
AND THAT WAS AUGUST 14TH AND
15TH OF 2020.
IT AFFECTED 500,000 CUSTOMERS.
IT LASTED 3.5 HOURS OVER TWO
NIGHTS.
UM, AND THE POSTURE IS NEVER
AGAIN.
AND SO WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN IN ADDITION TO THE STORAGE.
ALSO JUST, UM, EVERYTHING THAT
CONNECTS TO
THE GRID TO MAKE IT A GOOD
CITIZEN OF THE GRID.
AND SO TO MAKE USE OF THE DEMAND
RESPONSE CAPABILITIES,
WE HAVE AN AUTHORITY I MENTIONED
EARLIER
SOME OF THE EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS.
ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING ONES
WAS
SENATE BILL SB 49, NANCY
SKINNER,
WHICH GAVE US THE ABILITY TO
REQUIRE
LOAD FLEX CAPABILITIES.
WE DID OUR FIRST ONE WITH POOL
PUMPS.
THAT'S 500MW OF LOAD.
AND WITH THAT STANDARD, YOU CAN
ASSURE THAT,
YOU KNOW, WHEN THOSE PUMPS ARE
OPERATING,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
OPERATING DURING PEAK.
IT'S ACTUALLY A FAIRLY SMALL
NUMBER OF HOURS OF THE YEAR
WHERE WE'RE REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT GRID RELIABILITY,
LIKE 30 TO 60 HOURS A YEAR,
JULY,
AUGUST, SEPTEMBER 4 TO 9.
AND THAT'S REALLY OUR CRUNCH
TIME.
AND SO OUR EFFORTS ARE REALLY
FOCUSED
ON REDUCING LOAD IN THOSE
PERIODS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PETER JONES.
>> THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN.
I WANTED TO KIND OF DIG DEEPER
A LITTLE
BIT ON THE HYDROGEN THING.
I WAS AT A CONFERENCE RECENTLY,
AND THEN I HAVE A SECOND
UNRELATED QUESTION AS WELL.
UM.
IT SEEMS LIKE, UM, OTHER STATES
ARE KIND OF
TAKING THE LEAD ON THE HYDROGEN
STUFF.
AND I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR
LIKES TO TALK ABOUT
CALIFORNIA TAKING THE LEAD ON
ENERGY,
ESPECIALLY RENEWABLE ENERGY
AND ZERO EMISSIONS AND ALL OF
THAT.
SO, UM, I THINK THE NUMBER I
HEARD WAS
THAT SOUTH CAROLINA IS INVESTING
OR
SOMEBODY EITHER THE CORPORATIONS
IT'S A PRIVATE PARTY
PARTNERSHIP.
I DIDN'T GET ALL THE DETAILS ON
IT SOMEWHERE
UPWARDS OF $5 BILLION ON THEIR
HYDROGEN HUB,
AND JUST WANTED TO KIND OF GET
YOUR THOUGHTS,
YOU KNOW,
IS CALIFORNIA GOING TO TAKE THE
LEAD ON HYDROGEN?
ARE WE GOING TO ALLOW OTHER
STATES
TO TAKE THE LEAD ON THIS?
UM, AND, YOU KNOW, MAYBE I'M
MORE
ASKING LIKE A GENERALIZED
QUESTION MORE THAN A SPECIFIC
QUESTION,
LIKE, WHAT'S THE CCS ATTITUDE
TOWARDS HYDROGEN?
AND ARE WE GOING TO GET THERE
ON IT?
YEAH.
AS I SAID, WE HAVE DEPLOYED
MORE HYDROGEN AND FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAN JUST ABOUT
ANY PLACE.
UM, AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, I
PERSONALLY SUPPORT
THE ARCHES APPLICATION WE
APPLIED ALONG WITH,
YOU KNOW, MANY OTHER STATES,
AND WE WERE FORTUNATE TO GET
ONE AWARD.
BUT, UM, YOU KNOW, WE CAN ONLY
DO WHAT
WE HAVE WITH THE FUNDS WE, WE
HAVE.
AND THAT WAS, UH, YOU KNOW, A
LIMITED
FEDERAL OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW.
OUR WE HAD ORIGINALLY $100
MILLION
FOR CLEAN HYDROGEN IN THE
BUDGET.
AND I KNOW YOUR BUDGET
CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
HAVE HAVE TIGHTENED
CONSIDERABLY.
UM, FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, YOU
KNOW,
I'M VERY INTERESTED TO SEE
HYDROGEN
FILL THE NICHES THAT CAN'T BE
MET WITH ELECTRIFICATION.
AND SO THERE ARE SOME OF THESE
END USE
APPLICATIONS I LOOK AT, YOU
KNOW,
HYDROGEN HOME PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT
HYDROGEN WATER HEATING.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD APPLICATION.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S ELECTRIC HEAT
PUMP.
HEAVY DUTY TRANSPORTATION IS
A DIFFERENT KETTLE OF FISH.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING RIGHT NOW
THAT YOU KNOW,
IS IS MORE, UM, UP FOR GRABS.
AND AND AS SENATOR GROVE
MENTIONED, YOU KNOW,
COMPANIES LIKE UNIVERSAL DOING,
UH, HYDROGEN FUEL FOR PLANES.
SO THOSE ARE NEVER GOING TO BE
LONG RANGE PLANES,
NOT GOING TO BE ELECTRIFIED.
RIGHT.
SO THAT IS, I THINK THE PUZZLE
PIECE
THERE TO FIT IT IN, IN A,
IN AN AREA OF NEED THAT'S
OTHERWISE
REALLY DIFFICULT TO ELECTRIFY.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF HEAVY DUTY
INDUSTRY,
STEEL MANUFACTURING AND SO ON.
THAT'S SUPER DIFFICULT TO
DECARBONIZE AND VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT TO ELECTRIFY
WHERE
I THINK HYDROGEN FITS.
OKAY.
AND THEN A SECOND TOPIC THAT
CAME UP AT THAT CONFERENCE,
AND I THINK YOU AND I HAVE
CHATTED ABOUT THIS IN,
IN PASSING IN THE PAST,
IS SOME STATES AND EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES ARE STARTING
TO CAN BUILD SMALL MODULAR
NUCLEAR REACTORS,
AND THEY SEEM TO BE SOLVING, UM,
SOME ZERO EMISSIONS CHALLENGES
FOR THOSE AREAS.
AND, YOU KNOW, DO YOU HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS ON
THAT AS CECI LOOKED AT THAT AND,
YOU KNOW,
IS THAT A CONVERSATION THAT
WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA,
OR IS IT A NONSTARTER FROM
THE BEGINNING OR AND AGAIN,
THAT'S A GENERALIZED QUESTION,
NOT NECESSARILY A SPECIFIC
QUESTION.
SURE.
NO.
VERY FAIR QUESTION.
SO CALIFORNIA BUILT AND
INSTALLED FIVE
NUCLEAR PLANTS HUMBOLDT, RANCHO
SECO,
UM, UH VALLECITOS, SAN ONOFRE
AND DIABLO
FOUR DECOMMISSIONED DIABLO
CELESTE.
UM.
AND UNDER CURRENT STATUTE,
IT'S NOT LEGAL TO CONSTRUCT A
NEW
NUCLEAR PLANT UNTIL YOU HAVE
A SOLUTION FOR THE WASTE.
THE WASTE FOR ALL OF THOSE
FACILITIES IS STILL
ON SITE UNDER STRICT SECURITY
PROTOCOLS,
SO THAT IS NOT AN OPTION.
I THINK WHAT IS AN OPTION IS
THE EXTENSION OF DIABLO.
AND I THINK REALLY THE WAY TO
THINK ABOUT IT,
THERE ARE REALLY TWO DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES.
UM, EXTENDING AN EXISTING
FACILITY IS
A LIGHTER LIFT THAN A NEW PLANT,
AND CERTAINLY THAT'S THE ONLY
THING
WE COULD DO IN THIS SPACE.
YOU KNOW, AS LONG AS THAT
STATUTE IS IN PLACE.
AND SO THAT JUST HAPPENED WITH
WITH
THE AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO HELP
SUPPORT OUR,
OUR RELIABILITY NEEDS.
BUT RIGHT NOW, IT'S NOT A NEW
NUCLEAR.
IT'S NOT AN OPTION UNTIL THAT,
UNLESS THAT STATUTE CHANGES.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT I GUESS WHAT I'M KIND OF
DRIVING TOWARDS IS, UM.
HAVING THE CONVERSATION.
YES.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S WHERE
CALIFORNIANS
KIND OF NEED TO GET IS, YOU
KNOW,
MAYBE NOT A SPECIFIC LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
BUT I THINK CALIFORNIA, IF WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE SERIOUS
GETTING TO ZERO EMISSIONS AND,
UM, AND GREEN ENERGY,
THAT NUCLEAR HAS TO BE A PART
OF THAT PORTFOLIO
AND WE NEED TO START HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION.
SO THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
LEADER.
I WOULD LIKE TO ADVANCE JUST
A FEW ITEMS.
UM, MR.
CHAIR, AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND
SOME TIME WITH YOU OVER THE LAST
FEW WEEKS,
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT GASOLINE
STORAGE
AND AUTHORITY WITH THE CEC.
AND I KNOW, MR.
DIRECTOR, IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
AS WELL.
I THINK THE WHILE.
THERE WAS SOME PRELIMINARY, UM,
LEGISLATION THAT WAS ADVANCED,
UM, BY THE LEGISLATURE, SIGNED,
UH, VIA GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE THAT AND
I DON'T
WANT TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH,
MR.
CHAIR, BUT THE CHALLENGE RIGHT
NOW
WHERE THE CDC DOES NOT HAVE
AUTHORITY IS MANDATING
ADDITIONAL
STORAGE FOR GASOLINE.
AND WHERE VICE CHAIR GROVE WAS
JUST TALKING
ABOUT I THINK WE ALL ARE
CONCERNED
IN REGARDS TO I'LL SAY WHAT
WE'LL
SEE THE SEASONAL PRICE SPIKES,
UM, ESPECIALLY DURING HEAVY
TRAVEL
MONTHS DURING THE LATE SPRING,
SUMMER AND EARLY FALL.
UM, AND THEN THE SECOND PIECE
IS,
IS ACTUALLY HAVING AUTHORITY.
CC HAVING AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE
TO,
UH, HAVE A FORMAL CONVERSATION
WITH REFINERIES ABOUT REFINERIES
COMING OFFLINE OR NOT.
UM, NOTICE IS GREAT, BUT TRULY,
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF TEETH
TO WHERE THE CEC CAN GO AT THE
MOMENT STATUTORILY.
UM, SO CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF STORAGE AND.
HAVING AUTHORITY TO TAKE
REFINERY HEALTH
AND SAFETY IS NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
EMERGENCY WORK IS OBVIOUSLY A.
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
BUT IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
STABILIZING THE MARKET,
IT'S GUARANTEEING THAT WE HAVE
MORE STORAGE IN STATE
AND HAVING SOME AUTHORITY TO BE
ABLE TO APPROVE OR
NOT WHEN IT COMES TO TAKING
REFINERIES OFFLINE.
YEAH.
SO JUST FOR CONTEXT, THIS
PROBLEM IS HARDER
TO SOLVE THAN STORAGE ON THE
GRID.
OKAY.
THE THE ADDITION OF TEN
GIGAWATTS OF ENERGY STORAGE.
I'M SORRY I KNOW, I KNOW, I KNOW
FOR YOUR TIME,
BUT I'M JUST SAYING RELATIVELY
LIKE WE WERE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY ADDRESS THAT
BECAUSE IT,
IT WAS POSSIBLE TO INSTALL TEN
GIGS
IN FIVE YEARS FOR REFINERS,
WHICH TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE VERY
MUCH STORAGE.
THERE'S LIKE 1 TO 2 DAYS OF
REFINED
FUEL STORAGE ON THESE SITES.
IT'S VERY, VERY THIN MARGIN.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE BUILD CYCLES
FOR
THOSE CAN BE SEVEN PLUS YEARS.
AND SO BY THE WAY, THAT'S WHERE
THESE VISITS WITH REFINERS
HAVE BEEN REALLY HELPFUL TO
GET CALIBRATED AROUND THAT.
SO THAT IS PART OF THE EXPOSURE
IS
JUST WE DON'T HAVE UM STORAGE.
THE STORAGE.
YEAH.
SO YOU KNOW, I DON'T WANT TO
OPINE ON NEW
AUTHORITIES BECAUSE WE WILL DO
WHAT YOU
TELL US TO DO THROUGH STATUTE
AND WITH
THE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE, WE DON'T
HAVE,
YOU KNOW, RIGHT NOW OUR
AUTHORITY IS TO REQUIRE
THE NOTICE ON PLANNED
MAINTENANCE AND SO ON,
RATHER THAN LIKE REARRANGE THE
CYCLES AND SO ON.
SO I THAT IS FOR THE GOVERNOR
AND YOU TO,
TO SORT OF WHAT YOU'D LIKE TO
HAVE US DO.
BUT I WILL JUST FRAME THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS.
AND THE CONSTRAINTS ARE GREATER
IN THE GASOLINE
MARKET THAN IN THE ELECTRIC
SECTOR.
YEAH.
NO, 100%.
AND I ALSO THINK THE LEAD TIME.
RIGHT.
AND BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
AND, UM,
I KNOW THAT I HEAR YOU AND
NEEDING TO
BE AND THIS IS MY TERMS, NOT
YOURS.
MR.
CHAIR.
I'M NOT TRYING TO PUT YOU INTO
AN AWKWARD POSITION,
BY THE WAY,
THAT YOU NEED TO PLAY IT SAFE ON
THIS AND UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS AN ADMINISTRATIVE CALL BY
THE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AND IF THE LEGISLATURE IS GOING
TO
GRANT YOU ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY,
CURRENTLY, THE CEC DOES NOT HAVE
AUTHORITY.
THAT'S CORRECT.
TO MOVE ON MANDATING AN
ADDITIONAL IN-STATE STORAGE
AND APPROVING KEEPING A REFINERY
ONLINE OR OFFLINE.
WE DO NOT HAVE AUTHORITY TO SHUT
DOWN A REFINERY OR FORCE IT.
YEAH, WE'RE WE'RE CONSTRAINED
ON THAT.
AND ALL RIGHT.
MORE TO COME ON THIS SIR.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
LIVING THE DREAM OKAY.
>> OKAY.
UM.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE
OF REGIONALIZATION.
AND I WANT TO BE 30,000FT UP
ON THIS ONE.
UM, I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE,
THIS IS MORE OF A STATEMENT
AND A QUESTION IS THAT, UH,
REGIONALIZATION HAS BEEN A HOT
TOPIC IN MANY WESTERN
STATES AND INCLUDING RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I KNOW THAT WE'LL KEEP IN
TIGHT CONTACT IN REGARDS
TO ANY REGIONALIZATION
DISCUSSIONS EFFORTS,
WHETHER IT'S WITHIN THE SHOP OF
THE CEC OR CAL ISO.
I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
OBVIOUSLY
THERE ARE VARYING OPINIONS,
AND I THINK A LOT OF INTEREST
ON ALL SIDES, UH,
REGARDING REGIONALIZATION,
AND IT IS GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS ON THAT.
AND AGAIN, I'M KEEPING IT
30,000FT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
NO.
AND I WOULD JUST, UM,
SAY VICE CHAIR GUND HAS BEEN
LEADING THAT EFFORT.
AND AGAIN, YOU KNOW, WE WE'RE
AN IMPLEMENTING AGENCY.
WE WILL DO WHAT DIRECTION WE
GET FROM FROM
FROM YOU ON STATUTE AND THE
GOVERNOR.
UM, AND I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS COMPLEX ISSUE OVER,
OVER MANY YEARS.
SO, UM, I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO, TO ENGAGE ON THAT.
APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WANTED TO CHECK IN.
YEAH.
TAKE IT AWAY, PLEASE.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
JUST A FOLLOW UP QUESTION.
SO THE YOU SAID TWO DAYS
STORAGE, ROUGHLY,
UM, AT THESE REFINERIES AND,
UM, UH, IS THAT A LOCAL ISSUE?
LIKE, I HEARD THAT WHEN REFINERY
WAS WAITING TWO YEARS
FOR TO INCREASE STORAGE CAPACITY
FROM A LOCAL ISSUE,
LIKE FROM, LIKE, UH, PERMITTING
TO.
YEAH, TO GET THE APPROVALS AND
THEN TO CONSTRUCT
THE TANKS IS WHAT THEY TOLD US.
AND THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
THERE'S A LOT OF PERMITS
FOR NEW FOSSIL FUEL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND, UM, SO IN THE DISCUSSIONS,
I MEAN,
I'M JUST RELAYING WHAT WE HEARD
FROM THE REFINERIES ABOUT THEIR
LEAD TIME TO CONSTRUCT THAT.
IT'S, UM, THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I
AND I HAVE NO REASON TO QUESTION
THAT.
THAT WAS WHAT THEY RELAYED WHEN
THEY
HAD LOOKED AT NEW, NEW TANKS.
AND THEN, UM, ONE MORE QUESTION.
WHEN YOU SAID THAT.
UM, AND BY THE WAY.
I JUST WOULD ADD THAT THAT IS
ALSO EXTRA COST
FOR THEM TO CARRY THAT AND TO
MAINTAIN IT.
AND SO I THINK THEY'RE
INTERESTED TO BE ABLE TO
TURN THE FUEL QUICKLY AND GET
IT TO MARKET.
SO I DON'T ALWAYS KNOW THAT
THE INCENTIVE IS THERE FOR THEM
TO.
THAT WAS MY NEXT TO DO THAT.
YEAH.
MY NEXT QUESTION WAS THE
INCENTIVE TO
GET THEM TO PUT FUEL ON THE
MARKET.
BASICALLY, I LOOK AT IT FROM
A BUSINESS IN THE REAL WORLD.
I'M A BUSINESS OWNER NOW,
TEMPORARY STAFFING.
BUT IF I TRAIN, SAFETY, TRAIN
DRUG TEST,
GIVE THEM SAFETY EQUIPMENT,
PUT THEM THROUGH CLASSES SO THAT
THEY KNOW HOW TO DO WELDING,
TESTING AND ALL THE STUFF.
AND.
AND I JUST LET HIM SIT IN MY
SAFETY ROOM,
AND I'M NOT MAKING ANY MONEY
OFF OF HIM.
IT'S THE SAME CONCEPT WITH
REFINERIES.
IF THEY'RE REQUIRED TO REFINE
AND STORE FUEL
IN A TANK FOR DAYS OR MONTHS
OR WHATEVER,
THEY'RE NOT MAKING MONEY ON THAT
PRODUCT.
WHEN IT GOES TO MAKE IT GO OUT
THE DOOR.
SO WOULD THERE BE ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATION TO FORCE THEM
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT REQUIRED TO DO IT NOW?
CORRECT?
YEAH.
AGAIN, I DON'T WANT TO GET OVER
MY PAY
GRADE ON THESE THINGS BECAUSE
SOME
OF THESE ARE POLICY CALLS FOR
YOU TO,
TO, TO MAKE WHAT I HAVE
EMPHASIZED.
AND THE VICE CHAIR HAS
EMPHASIZED
IN EVERY ONE OF OUR MEETINGS,
WE DON'T HAVE TO ACTUALLY AGREE
ON ALL THE ISSUES.
WE HAVE TO AGREE ON NO MORE,
YOU KNOW,
GASOLINE PRICE SPIKES.
AND THAT'S THE GOAL.
AND, YOU KNOW, LOOKING
COMPREHENSIVELY
AT HOW DO WE SOLVE THAT?
WE'VE HAD PRICE SPIKES IN THREE
OUT OF THE LAST FIVE YEARS,
2019, 2022 AND 2023.
AND THEY PLACE A HUGE BURDEN
ON FAMILIES,
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES,
WHERE FUEL COSTS ARE MUCH HIGHER
SHARE OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD INCOME.
AND YOU KNOW, WE HAVE JUST BEEN
LASER FOCUSED
ON THAT AND IT'S
MULTI-DIMENSIONAL.
UM, AND, YOU KNOW, I UNDERSTAND
THEIR CONSTRAINT.
WE HAVE CONSTRAINTS.
UM, BUT THAT'S BEEN OUR MAIN,
OUR MAIN MESSAGE.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE
ASKING,
WOULD I APPRECIATE HAVING MORE
STORAGE
IN CALIFORNIA FOR FINE FUELS?
THAT WOULD MAKE ME FEEL BETTER,
THAT THERE'S MORE CUSHION.
UM, AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
MAKES ME FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH ON THE
GRID NOW,
NOW WITH OUR POSTURE WITH, WITH
OUTAGES.
SO BUT, UM, THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
SO WITH THE SUPPLY CHAIN IN
CALIFORNIA
IS EXTENSIVELY LONG,
LIKE OUR SUPPLY CHAIN FOR ENERGY
FUEL FOR EITHER REFINED FUEL OR,
OR CRUDE THAT COMES FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES OR THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
THERE'S A LEAD TIME.
A LEAD ON THAT AS WELL.
YEAH.
I MEAN WE COULD PRODUCE IT IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY,
SEND IT 200 MILES SOUTH AND
ELIMINATE
A LOT OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
BUT WE DON'T DO THAT.
WE GET IT FROM SAUDI ARABIA,
ECUADOR.
THAT IS A COST.
SHIPPING COSTS, TRANSPORTATION
COSTS,
LABOR COSTS OF THE PORT,
OFFLOADING COSTS TO OUR
REFINERIES TO PRODUCE IT,
TO GO TO THE JOBBERS, TO GO TO
MARKET.
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN IS A
SIGNIFICANT COST.
WOULD YOU AGREE OR NOT?
>> UH, I.
WOULD OBSERVE THAT.
WELL, IT IS TRUE.
WE DO WE DO IMPORT, UM, YOU
KNOW,
WHEN WHEN THAT'S INDICATED AND
THERE'S
A LONG LEAD TIME FOR THAT.
SO THAT'S A, THAT'S A THAT'S
TRUE.
YEAH.
I MEAN, SEVERAL WEEKS TO GET
FUEL FROM YOU KNOW,
IF YOU NEED REFINERIES IN KOREA
ELSEWHERE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
SIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND VICE CHAIR, PLEASE WELCOME
BACK.
SENATOR LAIRD IS.
YEAH, I HAVE THE BENEFIT OF NOT
HURTING A THING THAT YOU SAID.
SO NO IDEA IF I WAS.
THE ONE THING I KNOW THAT DIDN'T
GET SAID
IS GRATEFUL FOR FOR YOU MEETING.
AND WHEN I INTERVIEWED HIM 13
YEARS AGO TO
GET APPOINTED TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION,
I POINTED OUT THAT I KNEW ONE OF
HIS PARENTS AND HIS MOTHER WAS
MY WOMEN'S STUDIES PROFESSOR AT
UC SANTA CRUZ, AND I GOT TO.
KNOW HIM IN A STATE OF 39
MILLION PEOPLE.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE, LAIRD,
TO KNOW EVERYBODY'S PARENTS?
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO KNOW.
>> WELL.
I JUST I JUST KNEW TO IN COLUSA
COUNTY
IN THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
NO, BUT THE BAD PART ABOUT IT
WAS, IS HE SAID,
OH, THAT'S RIGHT, I WAS BORN IN
SANTA CRUZ,
WHICH MEANT HE'S 20 YEARS
YOUNGER THAN ME,
WHICH WAS A PUNCH TO THE GUT.
UM, SO LET ME ASK.
I AM SURE YOU TALKED ABOUT WIND,
BUT LET ME CHECK TO SEE THE THE
REPORT
ON AB 525 HAS JUST BEEN
RELEASED.
CAN YOU COMMENT.
ON YES I.
DID.
WE HAD A NEARLY NEARLY FOUR HOUR
HEARING ON THAT THIS MORNING.
WE POSTPONED THE VOTE ON THAT.
UM, SO.
YOU COULD BE HERE.
TO NEXT MONTH.
WE, WE UH WELL, FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS, THE,
THE FINAL DRAFT GOT RELEASED
LATER
THAN WE WOULD HAVE LIKED, SO.
BUT WE DID TAKE COMMENT.
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING EXTENSIVELY
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS.
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO, YOU KNOW,
ALL THE TRIBES KARUK, HUPA,
YUROK, UM, BIG LAGOON, BLUE
LAKE,
RANCHERIA, COSTANOA,
ESTERLINE, ALL THE EJ GROUPS,
COORS, BRIGHTLINE, DEFENSE,
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS, UH
FISHERIES,
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
UM, IN THE COURSE OF THIS
PROCESS, UM,
WE RECEIVED OVER 500 PAGES OF
WRITTEN PUBLIC COMMENTS.
WE'VE DONE OUR VERY BEST TO
INCORPORATE THOSE.
UM, I WILL JUST SPEAK A LITTLE
MORE BROADLY
ABOUT OFFSHORE WIND AS A
RESOURCE.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS 583MI² HAVE
BEEN LEASED OF FEDERAL WATERS.
THEY'RE 20 MILES OFFSHORE,
BOTH OFF THE CENTRAL COAST,
MORRO BAY THAT YOU REPRESENT,
AND THE NORTH COAST SENATOR
MCGUIRE REPRESENTS.
UH, AND THESE ARE FOR FLOATING
WIND TURBINES.
THE SCALE OF THESE PROJECTS IS
LARGE.
SO ONE ROTATION OF THE TURBINE
CAN
POWER TWO HOUSES FOR A DAY.
THE WIND RESOURCE OFFSHORE IS
FAR SUPERIOR TO WIND ON LAND.
SO IT'S BLOWING MORE HOURS OF
THE DAY,
AND IT'S HIGHLY COINCIDENT WITH
WHEN OUR DEMAND IS HIGHEST.
SO IT'S LATE AFTERNOONS IN THE
IN
THE SUMMER AND REALLY IS GOING
TO ALLOW
US TO RETIRE MORE OF THE
POLLUTING FACILITIES
THAT ARE SO CONTROVERSIAL.
THE OTC PLANTS ON THE COAST THAT
WE'VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT.
I WANT TO JUST RECOGNIZE SOME
LONGTIME FOLKS
IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY,
JOSHUA ARCE AND EDDIE ANN,
WHO I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
WE HAD A BIG FIGHT YEARS AGO IN
SAN FRANCISCO FOR,
YOU KNOW, TWO, UH,
POLLUTING PEAKER POWER PLANTS
AND LOW
INCOME AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER,
THERE ARE JUSTICE ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH ENERGY AND TO
BUILD A HEALTHY FUTURE
AND TO GET TO 100% CLEAN ENERGY
REQUIRES
A LOT OF DIFFERENT ACTIONS,
INCLUDING, YOU KNOW, NEW
RESOURCES LIKE THIS.
BUT EVEN THIS IS PRESENTING NEW
COMPLEXITIES.
AND SO, UM.
SO DID THE REPORT.
TODAY LAY OUT A ROADMAP.
THE REPORT LAYS LAYS OUT A
ROADMAP.
AND FOR ALL THE AGENCIES.
BRIEF HIGH LEVEL.
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THAT.
IS.
SO IT'S PRINCIPALLY ABOUT HOW
THE AGENCIES WORK TOGETHER.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME SENSE
AND JUST WITHIN OUR MOTHERSHIP
AGENCY,
WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY,
WE ARE WORKING DIRECTLY ON THIS
ISSUE
WITH THE LANDS COMMISSION,
WHICH IS GOING TO DO CEQA,
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL,
THE FISH AND WILDLIFE,
UM, COASTAL COMMISSION.
AND THEN THERE'S A DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR EQUITY,
A SENIOR DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
TRIBAL CNHA,
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR EQUITY.
EVERYBODY IS ENGAGED.
PLUS WE'RE DEALING WITH WITH
BOEM, PUC AND OTHERS.
SO HUGELY COMPLEX PROCESS AND IT
IS DECENTRALIZED.
WE DON'T PERMIT AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION OFFSHORE WIND.
WE DON'T PERMIT TRANSMISSION.
WE HAVE MORE OF A COORDINATION
RULE.
THE REPORT THAT I WAS DESCRIBING
TODAY IS THE FINAL
OF FOUR REPORTS THAT WERE
MANDATED UNDER SB,
UH, AB 525 BY DAVID CHU.
AND THERE'S TWO ADDITIONAL
REPORTS THAT YOU'VE
SENT TO US FROM AB, THREE
ASSEMBLYMEN ZEBRA,
THAT WILL REQUIRE REALLY
FOCUSING MORE
ON THE INDUSTRIAL SIDE OF IT.
HOW DO WE DO THIS WITH
MANUFACTURING
THAT BENEFITS THE STATE,
KEEPING THOSE JOBS HERE AS
WE MANUFACTURE THE TOWERS,
THE THE BLADES AND THE NACELLES?
UM, SO THIS THIS STRATEGIC PLAN
KIND OF REPRESENTS
HOW THOSE PIECES FIT TOGETHER
AND WHAT THE KEY STAKEHOLDERS
ARE SAYING,
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT.
THERE'S, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
CONCERN ON THE TRIBAL SIDE,
MAKING SURE THEY'RE AT THE TABLE
AND HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD AND
HAVE
A CHANCE TO TO WEIGH IN ON ALL
THE KEY DECISIONS AND THEN SOME.
I THINK VERY FAIR QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT ARE THE IMPACTS
OF OFFSHORE WIND ON EXISTING
ECOSYSTEMS,
FISHERIES AND SO FORTH.
I HAVE HAD THE CHANCE, IN THE
COURSE OF MY WORK,
TO TRAVEL AND SEE FLOATING
WIND PROJECTS IN PORTLAND,
SCOTLAND, NORWAY NORWAY JUST
INSTALLED
THE LARGEST FLOATING WIND
PROJECT I RECALL.
YOU GOT INCREDIBLY SOAKED.
I DID, I.
GOT ON THE FRONT OF THE BOAT
AND AS SOON AS WE GOT TO THE
THING,
A HUGE WAVE CRASHED OVER ME.
SO IT WAS MEMORABLE, UH,
MEMORABLE FIRST VISIT.
UM, BUT WE HAVE A LOT TO LEARN
FROM OUR EUROPEAN PARTNERS.
DENMARK HAS BEEN DOING OFFSHORE
WIND FOR 35 YEARS.
THEY HAVE 500 TURBINES OFFSHORE.
AND SO WHILE WE'VE BEEN LEADING
ON ALL THESE OTHER THINGS, UM,
OFFSHORE WIND IS ONE WHERE WE
HAVE
A LOT TO LEARN FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES.
SO WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON THAT.
I JUST, UH, IN CLOSING,
WANT TO REALLY THANK OUR
TERRIFIC NEW
OFFSHORE WIND ADVISOR WHO'S
BEEN HELPING LEAD ALL THIS,
AND THAT'S JANET GAGNON, UH,
THAT WAS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR A FEW MONTHS AGO.
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO ADOPTING
THE STRATEGIC PLAN,
HOPEFULLY AT THE NEXT BUSINESS
MEETING IN JULY.
UM, THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL.
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
ALTHOUGH I CAN JUST TELL YOU,
SENATOR GROVE LOVED THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY BEING REFERRED
TO AS THE MOTHERSHIP.
AND I SUSPECT THAT IS THE NOT
THE LAST TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR ABOUT.
THAT.
THANK YOU FOR AND I WOULD ASK
ABOUT OTHER THINGS,
BUT I WAS SATISFIED IN OUR
MEETING
AND I'M SURE THEY'VE BEEN TALKED
ABOUT.
AND SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR
LAIRD.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE
IF THERE'S
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE BEFORE WE
OPEN
IT UP TO THOSE IN ATTENDANCE.
SEEING NONE.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
DO IS OPEN
UP OUR PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION
UNDER.
MR.
CHAIR, WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOLKS
TO PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME,
THE ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE
WITH.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP EACH
INDIVIDUAL
COMMENT TO 30S OR LESS.
WE WELCOME YOU.
PLEASE.
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU.
WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU FOR RECEIVING OUR
COMMENTS.
MY NAME IS DAN SHUGAR, FOUNDER
CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF NEXTRACKER.
WE'RE A CALIFORNIA COMPANY WITH
500 APPROXIMATELY
EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE,
SHIPPING PRODUCTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY
AND AROUND THE WORLD,
INCLUDING MANUFACTURING IN
CALIFORNIA,
WITH TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF PRODUCT BEING MADE IN
THE STATE BEING SHIPPED OUT.
I'D LIKE TO, ON BEHALF OF OUR
COMPANY.
PROVIDE OUR STRONGEST
ENDORSEMENT
FOR COMMISSIONER ROTHSCHILD,
HIS WORK HAVING WORKED IN
RENEWABLE ENERGY
FOR 36 YEARS AND BEING A GLOBAL
COMPANY,
I CAN SAY BASED ON OUR
EXPERIENCE,
HE'S THE TOP PUBLIC ENERGY
POLICY PERSON
GLOBALLY THAT WE'VE EVER WORKED
WITH AND HAS DONE MORE TO
ADVANCE RENEWABLE
ENERGY THAN ANYBODY I KNOW,
AND HAS HELPED CALIFORNIA
ADVANCE ITS ROLE
IN CLEAN ENERGY HERE FOR OUR
CITIZENS,
AND ALSO CREATE A VERY STRONG
ECONOMIC BASE FOR COMPANIES
LIKE NEXTRACKER TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE BOTH CALIFORNIA,
UH, THE THE COUNTRY AND THE REST
OF THE WORLD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
SPEAKER.
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> WELCOME, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
JIM HAWLEY, I'M AT LAWRENCE
BERKELEY
NATIONAL LABORATORY,
THE NATIONAL LABORATORY MANAGED
BY
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
AND I'LL CLARIFY MY MY REMARKS
ON MY OWN DO NOT REPRESENT
OFFICIAL VIEWS OF THE LAB OR
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY,
BUT I WANT TO SAY THAT CHAIR
HOCHUL'S
LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN ESTABLISHING THE STATE AS
A GLOBAL LEADER IN THE RESEARCH,
DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT OF
NEW
CLEAN ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES.
HE'S WORKED INCREDIBLY
EFFECTIVELY
TO SUPPORT THE INNOVATIONS
AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP NEEDED TO
DEVELOP
NEW CLEAN ENERGY SOLUTIONS,
TO MAKE SURE THAT STATE
INVESTMENTS ARE EQUITABLY
MADE TO CREATE HIGH ROAD JOBS
ACROSS THE STATE.
IN PARTICULAR, HIS STEWARDSHIP
HAS POSITIONED
THE STATE TO WIN SOME
SUBSTANTIAL FEDERAL INVESTMENT
FOR CLEAN ENERGY IN AREAS SUCH
AS WATER REUSE,
GREEN HYDROGEN AND MANY OTHER
AREAS.
SO PLEASED TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SO MUCH.
THANKS FOR COMING IN TODAY.
HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M SARAH FITZSIMON.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF CALPINE
AND INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION,
AND WE'RE HERE TO OFFER OUR
STRONG
SUPPORT FOR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU.
SO MUCH.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> HEY.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
UH, TIFFANY FAN, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY
AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT,
ALSO ON BEHALF OF INTERSECT
POWER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELCOME.
>> HI.
SAMANTHA SAMUELSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION COALITION HERE
IN SUPPORT OF
THE CHAIR AND VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF ALL OF HIS
LEADERSHIP ON BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HEY.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HI, EMILY PAPPAS FOR NIEMELA
PAPPAS AND ASSOCIATES,
ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT, MCE
IN SUPPORT.
COULD YOU SEE PAPPAS?
THANK YOU.
THANK GOOD AFTERNOON.
HELLO, MOLLY.
KROLL WITH AMERICAN CLEAN POWER
ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT CHAIR.
IT HAS BEEN A TIRELESS LEADER
IN ADVANCING
CALIFORNIA AS A GLOBAL CLEAN
ENERGY HUB.
SO THANK YOU.
AND ALSO WANTED TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT
FOR CAL WHO COULDN'T BE HERE.
BUT UM, ALSO WANTED TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR.
GORE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON, AARON COONS
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION,
GOLDEN STATE WIND ENERGY SOURCE
MINERALS,
THE CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE
ENERGY,
SMUD, MP MATERIALS AND TORAH,
EDF RENEWABLES,
EDP RENEWABLES,
HYDROSTOR AND SCALE MICROGRIDS
ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THE CHAIR'S
CONFIRMATION.
I DAMN.
THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
UM, THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE HERE.
AARON GRIZZARD WITH INVENERGY.
I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS.
AND CONGRATULATIONS TO SENATOR
EGGMAN
ON HER AWARD TODAY AS WELL.
UM, WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT
FOR THE CHAIR'S REAPPOINTMENT.
CLEARLY, AS THE DISCUSSION HAS
ILLUSTRATED TODAY,
HE DOESN'T SHY AWAY FROM
COMPLEXITY
AND MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS, WE'RE
REALLY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF HIS
REAPPOINTMENT.
SO THANK.
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
>> WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
EDDIE ON, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
BRIGHTLINE DEFENSE ORGANIZATION
FORGED BY ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
STRUGGLES AT HOCHSCHILD,
MENTIONED EARLIER ANYTHING
RANGING
FROM POWER PLANT, YOU KNOW,
SITING TO LOW INCOME, YOU KNOW,
HOUSEHOLDS GETTING SOLAR.
FOR US, WE REALLY CARE ABOUT
THE NEXUS
OF JOBS AND CLEAN ENERGY AND
EQUITY.
AND WITH THAT, LIKE THAT
UNDERSTANDING
OF POLICY AND POLITICS,
I THINK IS EXTREMELY RARE.
AND I THINK WITH THIS COMMISSION
APPOINTMENT,
YOU'LL GET THAT.
EXACTLY THAT.
AND MOST OF ALL, THE EMPATHY FOR
COMMUNITIES IS EVEN RARER.
SO WITH THAT IN FULL SUPPORT,
THANK YOU.
VERY NICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> HEY, HEY.
HELLO, MICHELLE CANALES,
ON BEHALF OF UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
DAVID HOCHSCHILD'S,
UM, REAPPOINTMENT AS CHAIR OF
THE ENERGY COMMISSION.
UH, DURING HIS TENURE, WE HAVE
SEEN
HIM ADVANCE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE,
BATTERY MANUFACTURING,
TECHNOLOGY AND SOURCING,
ESTABLISHED NECESSARY AND
AMBITIOUS OFFSHORE
WIND GOALS AND PLAN FOR
THE CLEAN GRID OF THE FUTURE.
UM, GIVEN OUR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AND ENERGY
GOALS AMID A WORSENING CLIMATE
CRISIS,
WE ARE CONFIDENT IN HIS ABILITY
TO CONTINUE
TO SUCCESSFULLY LEAD THE ENERGY
COMMISSION.
THANK YOU.
THANKS, MICHELLE.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, LILLIAN
MERVIS.
WITH THE LARGE SCALE SOLAR
ASSOCIATION CHAIR,
HOCHSCHILD HAS SHOWN EXEMPLARY
LEADERSHIP WITH
HELPING CALIFORNIA MEET ITS SB
100 GOALS,
AND WE ARE PLEASED TO PROVIDE
OUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS
BRIAN WHITE HERE
ON BEHALF OF OFFSHORE WIND
CALIFORNIA,
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF CHAIR
HOCHSCHILD'S CONFIRMATION.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, I'VE KNOWN
CHAIR
HOCHSCHILD FOR OVER TEN YEARS,
AND HE'S JUST AS PASSIONATE
TODAY AS HE WAS
BACK THEN WORKING IN THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY.
AND NOW I GET TO WORK ON JUST
ABOUT EVERY
ISSUE THAT HIS AGENCY IS WORKING
ON,
WHETHER IT'S HYDROGEN, LITHIUM,
OFFSHORE WIND AND SOLAR.
SO I WILL TELL YOU THAT YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO FIND
A BETTER PROFESSIONAL THAN CHAIR
HOCHSCHILD.
SO WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT HIS
CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> HI.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS,
JOSHUA ARCE WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA LABORERS UNION.
I WANT TO SAY ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL,
HAVING WORKED WITH THE
COMMISSION PRESIDENT,
DAVID HOCHSCHILD, FOR 17 YEARS
NOW,
I'VE ALWAYS FOUND HIM TO BE A
LIFELONG,
COMMITTED ADVOCATE FOR CLEAN
ENERGY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE WHEN IT COMES TO 30,000
MEMBERS OF OUR UNION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND 70,000
LABORERS UNION MEMBERS STATEWIDE
WHO WORK IN INFRASTRUCTURE,
PARTICULARLY HELPING BUILD
THE CLIMATE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
YOU'RE ADVANCING AND THAT HE
LEADS AT THE COMMISSION.
HE'S NEVER LOST SIGHT OF LABOR
STANDARDS.
HE'S NEVER SOUGHT SIGHT OF THE
QUALITY OF
JOBS AND WORKING WITH UNIONS
TO HELP
BUILD OUT THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
AND COGNIZANT
OF THE NEED FOR A JUST
TRANSITION,
BECAUSE WE STILL DO HAVE
THOUSANDS OF UNION
MEMBERS WORKING IN LEGACY
INDUSTRIES.
HE'S ALWAYS LOOKED OUT FOR US
AND MAKING THAT TRANSITION
INTO THE CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE,
JUST LIKE YOU ALL.
HEY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIRMAN, CHAIRPERSON AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M SANJIV, I'M THE FOUNDER AND
CEO OF
LFP BATTERY COMPANY CALLED
SPARKS.
AND WE ARE SETTING UP WHAT WILL
POSSIBLY BE THE FIRST AND
THE LARGEST BATTERY GRADE
PRODUCTION
FACILITY OUTSIDE OF CHINA.
HERE, NOT TOO FAR FROM HERE FOR
LFP BATTERIES.
AND IT'S ALL BECAUSE OF CHAIRMAN
DAVE HOCHSCHILD.
WE WERE GOING TO SET IT UP IN
A STATE CALLED TENNESSEE,
AND HE CONVINCED ME TO BRING
THE MANUFACTURING TO CALIFORNIA.
SO HE SHARED HIS VISION OF THE
LITHIUM VALLEY,
WHICH INCLUDES DOMESTIC
MANUFACTURING,
DOMESTIC SUPPLY CHAIN.
AND WE ARE VERY PROUD TO SAY
THAT
THIS WILL BE OUR FIRST FACTORY.
AND THE SECOND ONE IS COMING
UP OR
IS GOING TO COME UP IN SALTON
SEA.
SO IT'S ALL ABOUT HIS VISION.
IT'S TO A GREAT EXTENT, HIS
TENACITY,
HIS PERSEVERANCE AND HIS HANDS
ON APPROACH.
SO WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE AS
PRIVATE
SECTOR TO HAVE SOMEBODY
LIKE HIM IN THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
WE ALSO DON'T HAVE TORNADOES
HERE, SO THAT'S GOOD.
HEY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
THANK YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
UM, MR.
PRO TEM AND COMMITTEE, UH,
KELLY BOYD WITH EQUINOR AND
ATLAS OFFSHORE WIND.
THAT'S OUR CALIFORNIA NAME.
UM, HERE TO SUPPORT CHAIR
HOCHSCHILD
FOR HIS REAPPOINTMENT.
UM, HE'S QUITE A VISIONARY, AND
HE'S A VISIONARY
WHO CAN IMPLEMENT AT THE SAME
TIME.
UM, HE MISSED A BOAT RIDE WITH
US IN NORWAY LAST YEAR BECAUSE
HE WENT HOME FOR HIS DAUGHTER'S
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION.
I THINK THOSE SAY GREAT THINGS
ABOUT HIM.
HE WAS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY,
LED TO AN MOU
THAT WAS SIGNED RECENTLY BETWEEN
THE,
THE GOVERNOR AND THE AND THE
COUNTRY OF NORWAY.
SO THE GLOBAL SPAN HERE FOR
CALIFORNIA,
A LOT OF THAT RESIDES WITH
THE CHAIR AND HIS ABILITY TO
BRING
ALL OF THESE VARIOUS
TECHNOLOGIES,
PRODUCTS, EVERYTHING TOGETHER
TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY.
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS
REAPPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
PRO TEM MEMBERS, SILVIO FERRARI,
ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
RENEW HOME, FORMERLY OHMCONNECT
AND REWIRING AMERICA,
FOR ALL THE REASONS OTHERS
HAVE ALREADY SAID IN VERY,
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF YOUR
REAPPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU.
SO MUCH.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HEY.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
UH, MEGAN MICKELBERG HERE ON
BEHALF OF CAL, START TODAY.
UM, REALLY, REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THE ZEV TRANSITION IN
PARTICULAR.
UM, OBVIOUSLY, THEY RUN QUITE
A FEW PROGRAMS HERE AT CEC
AND VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING.
ALSO, JUST WANTED TO PUT IN
SUPPORT
FOR THE EV CHARGING ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MEGAN.
GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHRIS ROSE,
ON BEHALF OF NRDC ACTION FUND,
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CHAIR'S
REAPPOINTMENT.
THANKS, CHRIS.
APPRECIATE IT.
WE'D LIKE TO DO A LAST CALL.
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT?
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
IF YOU CAN, PLEASE COME FORWARD
AT THIS TIME.
HERE AND SEEING NO ONE, WE'RE
GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BETTER
SEE
IF AN INDIVIDUAL WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE
TO ADVANCE A MOTION FOR
APPROVAL.
MADAM VICE CHAIR PUTS A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR TO
ADVANCE THE NOMINATION TO THE
SENATE FLOOR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL?
MCGUIRE.
RAY MCGUIRE.
AYE.
GROVE.
GROVE I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I JONES I JONES I LAIRD.
4 TO 0 ON CALL.
THAT'S A40 VOTE.
THAT MEASURE WILL BE ON CALL.
MISTER CHAIR, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M SURE THAT SENATOR LAIRD
IS GOING
TO BE THERE WITH YOU AS WELL,
SO.
BUT I'LL DO A EARLY
CONGRATULATIONS.
WE'LL SEE YOU ON THE SENATE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
COMMITTEE,
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
DO IS BEFORE
WE GO INTO OUR EXECUTIVE
SESSION,
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING
INTO
AN EXECUTIVE SESSION
MOMENTARILY,
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO CATCH
SOME FOLKS UP
ON VOTES AND THEN WE'LL GO INTO
EXECUTIVE
SESSION AND ALLOW TIME FOR
INDIVIDUALS
TO BE ABLE TO LEAVE THE HEARING
ROOM.
AND WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE BEING
HERE TODAY.
SO WHY DON'T WE DO THIS?
WHY DON'T WE START WITH GOVERNOR
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR?
WE HAVE NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
I'M GOING TO START WITH REQUIRED
TO APPEAR,
UH, WHICH ARE TWO MEDICAL BOARD
APPOINTEES.
THAT'S CURRENTLY A30 VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS?
GROVE.
I 4 TO.
0 AS FOUR ZERO.
VOTE.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THAT ON
CALL.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO
GOVERNOR.
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS?
GROVE.
I 5.
TO 0 FIVE.
ZERO.
WE'RE GOING TO SHUT DOWN.
GOVERNOR.
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR WITH A50 VOTE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO BILL
REFERRALS.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS?
GROVE?
GROVE I 5 TO 0.
THAT'S A50 VOTE.
FINAL VOTE.
WE'RE GOING TO SHUT THAT DOWN
AS WELL.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE GOING
TO FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS.
UM, THIS MOTION IS TO APPROVE
THESE ITEMS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO.
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER GROVE.
GROVE I 5.
TO 0 RIGHT IS.
A50 VOTE.
I DON'T VOTE AND WE'RE GOING TO
SHUT THAT DOWN.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING.
UH, THAT'S IT ACTUALLY, UM,
UNTIL WE COME BACK TO OUR CHAIR.
HOCHSCHILD.
UM, ITEM THAT IS CURRENTLY ON
CALL.
SO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO NOW,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO RECESS
HERE.
UM, WE'RE GOING TO RECESS INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION,
AND WE'LL COME BACK AND INTO
REGULAR SESSION
ON CALL WAITING FOR SENATOR
LAIRD,
WHO'S CURRENTLY VOTING IN THE
LABOR COMMITTEE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION
IF WE CAN HAVE FOLKS PLEASE
CLEAR THE HEARING ROOM.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING THE RULES
COMMITTEE
BACK OUT OF EXECUTIVE SESSION.
COMING BACK INTO REGULAR
SESSION,
WE HAVE ONE OUTSTANDING ITEM
THAT WE'D LIKE
TO ADD A MEMBER TO AND THAT IS
TO CHAIR HOCHSCHILD,
MEMBER OF THE TWO TWO.
YES WE DO.
YEAH.
WE HAVE TWO.
WE HAVE OUR TWO MEMBERS OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD,
ALONG WITH CHAIR HOCHSCHILD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION.
SO WHY DON'T WE OPEN THE ROLL
FOR, UM,
ABSENT MEMBERS FOR ITEMS ONE
A AND ONE B?
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL?
LAIRD?
AYE, LAIRD.
I 5 TO 0 FIVE ZERO.
THOSE TWO ITEMS ARE OUT.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLL.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING
ON TO ITEM
ONE C CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL?
LAIRD.
LAIRD I 5 TO 0.
FIVE ZERO VOTE.
THAT ITEM IS OUT AND WE'RE
CLOSING THE RULE.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WE ARE DOWN TO MADAM SECRETARY.
TWO MEETINGS, THREE MINUTES,
THREE, THREE MEETINGS.
AND WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SENATOR
LAIRD'S
DREAM COME TRUE FOR 4TH OF JULY.
WE'RE HAVING A JULY 3RD MEETING.
IT'S JUST ONE OF MANY DREAMS,
AC.
THERE WE GO.
EXACTLY.
SO HE'S GOING TO WEAR HIS
PATRIOTIC
SUNGLASSES AND READY TO GO.
YES.
THIS SENATE RULES COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU.